vous faire part du décès de nos anciens
collègues Claude Saunier qui fut
sénateur des côtes du nord puis les
Côtes-d'Armor de 1989 à 2008 et Henri
Lebreton qui fut sénateur du Morbihan de
1981 à 2001
monsieur le ministre madame le ministre
mes chers collègues j'ai le plaisir de
saluer la présence dans la tribune
d'honneur d'une délégation du Sénat
roumain
qu'on faisait de Monsieur Angel tilva
président de la commission aux Affaires
européennes du scénarumain monsieur
Robert Marius kazanciuk vice-président
du Sénat roumain madame Hansa dragou
président de la commission des droits de
l'homme l'égalité des chances des cultes
et des minorités du scénaron et ancienne
président du Sénat et le monsieur Vlad
verset à poufou secrétaire de la
commission des affaires européennes du
Sénat la venue de la commission des
affaires européennes du Sénat roumain
s'inscrit dans un agenda danse entre nos
deux chambres puisqu'il y a exactement
une semaine
le président Larcher recevait la
présidente du Sénat de Roumanie madame
Giorgio
une réunion commune entre les deux
commissions et prévu tout à l'heure pour
débattre dans jeu majeur la guerre en
Ukraine la crise énergétique les progrès
de la Roumanie vers son entrée dans
Schengen sans oublier naturellement la
coopération bilatérale entre la Roumanie
et la France qui s'inscrit dans le cadre
de l'amitié ancienne qui dîne aux deux
pays depuis l'émergence de la Roumanie
comme l'état au 19e siècle je me
félicite que les commissions des
affaires européennes de nos deux
chambres entretiennent ainsi un dialogue
régulier qui continue à nourrir cette
qui contribue pardon à nourrir cette
amitié précieuse je tiens donc à
souhaiter en votre nom à nos collègues
roumains un séjour fructueux en France
[Applaudissements]
l'ordre du jour appelle la discussion du
projet de loi adoptée par l'Assemblée
nationale portant en mesure d'urgence
relative au fonctionnement du marché du
travail en vue du plein emploi dans la
discussion générale la parole est à
Monsieur Olivier du socle ministre du
Travail du plein emploi et de
l'insertion
président madame la présidente de la
commission mais Madame et Monsieur les
rapporteur mesdames et messieurs les
sénateurs madame la ministre chers
Carole j'ai beaucoup de plaisir à être
devant vous pour présenter ce texte
premier texte relatif en plein emploi et
portant un certain nombre de mesures
d'urgence pour atteindre cet objectif du
plein emploi il s'agit en effet du
premier texte qui renvoie à ce bel
objectif de plein emploi et c'est sans
doute pas le dernier texte du
quinquennat en la matière en tout cas
c'est le premier qui nous permet
collectivement d'examiner un certain
nombre de mesures permettant de
concourir à cet objectif il faudra
appeler depuis 45 ans la France n'a plus
connue le plein emploi et nous ne devons
pas nous résigner à cette situation nous
avons même fait un une part importante
du chemin pour résoudre cette situation
et atteindre cet objectif nous avons en
effet créé la France en effet créé par
son économie sur les cinq dernières
années 1,7 millions tant comme salarié
comme indépendant et les deux dernières
années ont vu quasiment la moitié de ses
créations nettes d'emploi ce qui est à
souligner puisque il y a deux ans et
demi au début de la période du covid
personne n'aurait imaginé que 830 000
emplois soient créés entre mars 2020 et
la période qui nous réunit aujourd'hui
c'est résultats et cette réussite en
matière de création d'emplois nous les
avons aussi obtenu par de profondes
réformes avec une plus grande
décentralisation de la négociation
collective avec des moyens plus
importants donnés à la formation je
pense notamment aux comptes personnel de
formation en plein d'investissement dans
les compétences je pense aussi bien
évidemment au développement de
l'apprentissage au cours des dernières
années il faut aussi souligner que tout
cela et ses créations d'emplois cette
diminution du taux de chômage ne sait
pas opéré au détriment soit des salariés
soit des entreprises et ainsi je crois
que nous avons dépassé une forme de
fausse opposition et peut-être
pouvons-nous espérer une nouvelle forme
de compromis social qui est en train de
se développer où l'emploi est des
compétences deviennent une compétence
une composante essentielle de la
compétitivité des entreprises et ne sont
plus abordées uniquement au regard de
leur coup ou de l'incertitude qui leur
est attachée
dans ce contexte vous êtes donc proposé
aujourd'hui le premier projet de loi du
quinquennat visant atteindre le pôle
emploi un projet de loi volontairement
resserré centré sur les mesures les plus
urgentes mais pas les moins importantes
pourquoi ce texte maintenant pourquoi
dans cette période et pourquoi ces
mesures il faut d'abord là aussi le
rappeler nous avons actuellement un taux
de chômage qui est encore le double de
celui de nos voisins européens et les
tensions de recrutement sont malgré cela
à leurs combles ce qui est une situation
évidemment insatisfaisante 60% des
entreprises éprouvent des difficultés à
recruter 30% des entreprises
industrielles nous disent être obligés
de limiter leur activité de fermer des
lignes de production de renoncer une
partie de leur carnet de commandes pour
des raisons de pénurie de main d'oeuvre
ces difficultés témoignent des efforts
que nous devons encore accomplir pour
finir de libérer le travail en France et
sans revenir sur les 8 axes de la
feuille de route du ministère du travail
que j'ai eu l'occasion de présenter
devant la commission des affaires
sociales je voudrais simplement
développer trois idées devant vous
la première et que le plein d'emploi
c'est d'abord continué à valoriser le
travail ce qui est un accentral de notre
mission en particulier il s'agit de
donner l'envie le goût aux jeunes du
travail et pour cela l'entreprise doit
être ouverte à l'école doit continuer de
s'ouvrir aux entreprises et avec mon
collègue de l'éducation nationale avec
notre Ministre délégué Carole Grangeon
nous souhaitons donner aux jeunes aux
enfants la connaissance et le goût pour
les métiers de l'artisanat de
l'industrie des bâtiments autant de
métiers fondamentaux sur lesquels repose
une grande part de notre vie économique
ce sont des formidables gisements
d'emploi qui progressent sans cesse ce
sont aussi des compétences pointues qui
évoluent de manière permanente très
emprise avec les nouvelles technologies
et bien souvent un rebours de leur image
qui s'est parfois dégradé avec le temps
à travers l'apprentissage et lycée
professionnel ce secteurs connaissent un
nouvel élan et nous le développerons
encore ces prochaines années la deuxième
idée que je veux partager avec vous
c'est que le plein d'emploi c'est aussi
l'emploi pour tous
dans la société du plein emploi que nous
voulons construire il faut que nous nous
attaquions résolument à tout ce qui
freine l'accès d'emploi des plus
fragiles d'entre nous ce ne sont pas
toujours des problèmes de qualification
ou de compétences ce sont aussi des
freins périphériques à l'emploi
susceptibles d'enfermer des personnes
dans des situations d'inactivité subies
ou de précarité la garde d'enfants la
mobilité font partie de ces sujets
structurels qui restent encore
insuffisamment traité de façon
systématique je suis convaincu que c'est
désormais le temps d'avancer sur ces
sujets et c'est d'ailleurs le chantier
que nous avons engagé autour de France
travail nous avons un certain nombre
d'expériences à valoriser notamment à
travers le service public de l'insertion
vers l'emploi à travers le plan
d'investissement dans les compétences
que nous devons capitaliser pour passer
à une nouvelle échelle je souhaite aussi
que les nombreux outils numériques
expérimenter ça et là se déploie pour
que les différents acteurs puissent
travailler en réseau d'une façon plus
efficace qu'aujourd'hui dans France
travail il y a aussi le projet
d'accompagner de manière beaucoup plus
intensive personnalisée et adaptée
l'ensemble des bénéficiaires du RSA
partir de là les bénéficiaires des
minima sociaux c'est un projet qui me
tient particulièrement à coeur l'État ne
peut pas se considérer comme kit de ses
devoirs de solidarité à l'égard des
allocataires du RSA juste parce qu'il
verse une allocation nous pouvons faire
valoir ses droits nous pouvons faire
valoir des devoirs pour les allocataires
du RSA mais de façon préalable l'état
aussi le devoir de leur donner une vraie
chance avec une offre d'insertion une
offre d'accompagnement partout sur le
territoire et évidemment adapté et
personnalisable nous continuerons aussi
à transformer notre système de formation
professionnelle pour accélérer la montée
en compétences pour répondre aux besoins
des actifs et des entreprises mais aussi
pour faire face aux enjeux de transition
numérique écologique et démographique
nous travaillons en ce sens c'est avec
ce projet de loi nous vous proposons de
donner une première impulsion en matière
de validation des acquis de l'expérience
mais Carole Grandjean ministre délégué
reviendra sur ce sujet dans un instant
enfin la troisième idée que je veux
partager avec vous c'est le fait que le
plein emploi ce sont aussi meilleurs
conditions de travail nous avons des
conditions de travail en France qui sont
parfois difficiles des situations
sociales sont parfois conflictuelles et
nous savons avoir des marges de progrès
en la matière là aussi pour résoudre des
tensions de recrutement les entreprises
devront aussi mieux intégrer mieux
valoriser les métiers faire évoluer leur
salarié nous les accompagnons pour cela
mais nous y veillerons aussi avec
attention car elles n'ont pas qu'un rôle
de production mais aussi une part à
prendre dans l'effort collectif à mener
pour parvenir au paiement
le texte que je vous présente
aujourd'hui vise donc à apporter un
certain nombre de réponses et la
première d'entre elles concerne
l'assurance chômage d'abord pour
rappeler que cette assurance chômage est
au coeur notre modèle de sécurité
sociale et professionnelle qu'elle a été
bâtie au fil du temps par les
partenaires sociaux pour devenir un
outil puissant à la fois service de la
mobilité mais aussi de la protection des
actifs au même titre que tous les autres
axes que j'ai déjà mentionnés nous
devons la perfectionner pour parvenir au
plein emploi il faut garder son
caractère protecteur garder son
universalité nous avons d'ailleurs
élargi son bénéfice à certains
démissionnaires et aux travailleurs
indépendants mais il faut la mettre
davantage au service d'un retour rapide
à l'emploi à l'emploi durable car à nos
yeux nues de la tête condamnés à une
forme d'Inn employabilité
il faut aussi le rappeler l'assurance
chômage nous avons déjà commencé à la
réformer en 2019 et cette réforme de
2019 vise avant tout à répondre à
l'explosion des contrats courts
explosion depuis 20 ans mais aussi
apporter une réponse définitive au
déficit structurel de l'assurance
chômage déficit client parti justement à
la prolifération des contrats entre 2009
et 2019 l'assurance chômage ainsi accusé
systématiquement un déficit de 2,9
milliards d'euros en moyenne et c'est la
raison pour laquelle nous avons apporté
deux transformations structurelles avec
un premier lieu un nouveau calcul des
allocations pour garantir le fait que
travailler soit toujours plus
rémunérateur que le chômage mais aussi
avec la mise en place d'un bonus malus
dans cette secteurs économiques très
utilisateurs de contrats et ainsi depuis
le 1er septembre 2022 ce sont 6000
entreprises qui ont recours de manière
plus importante que la médiane de leur
secteur au contrat court qui paye une
surcréisation chômage je malus pouvant
aller jusqu'à un point de cotisation
supplémentaire sur l'ensemble de leur
masse salariale et 12.000 entreprises
qui bénéficient en revanche d'un bonus
pouvant aller jusqu'à 1, numéro 5% de
leur masse salariale j'entends
évidemment que des critiques s'élèvent
parfois de vos rond à l'égard du bonus
malus et vous avez d'ailleurs relayé ces
critiques à travers une réécriture de
l'article 2 du projet de loi à de tel
qu'il avait été adopté par l'Assemblée
nationale je veux cependant à cet égard
appeler quelques faits les contrats
courts coûtent structurellement à
l'assurance chômage quelques 2 milliards
d'euros par an et c'est pour cette
raison que nous avons voulu ré-attribuer
une partie de ce coup aux entreprises
qui le faisait peser d'une certaine
manière sur l'ensemble de la communauté
contributive et du même coup les
responsabilisé le bonus malus prendra
évidemment du temps pour produire tous
ses effets et nous vous demandons lui
donner ce temps pour que les 7 secteurs
aujourd'hui concernés en prennent la
mesure mais aussi comment ça modifier
plus profondément encore le recours au
contrats il y a de nombreuses
alternatives possibles avec des CDI
intérimaires des groupements
d'employeurs d'autres formes d'emploi
que nous voulons promouvoir et
accompagner
pour revenir au calendrier d'examen de
ce texte et répondre à la question
pourquoi agir à nouveau aujourd'hui les
règles actuelles sont définies par le
décret du 28 juillet 2019 dit des crêtes
carence venue définir les règles de
l'assurance chômage puisque les
partenaires sociaux n'étaient pas
parvenus à un accord ce décret arrive à
échéance les 1er novembre prochain et ce
qui motive le principe d'urgence de ce
projet de loi et le souhait que nous
avons de prolonger les règles jusqu'au
31 décembre 2023 pour laisser le temps à
la réforme de 2019 de déployer tous ses
effets nous souhaitons aussi prolonger
le bonus malus jusqu'au 31 août 2024
ouvrir dès aujourd'hui un nouveau cycle
de négociation n'aurait pas eu grand
sens du fait de la crise sanitaire les
nouvelles règles ne sont en train en
vigueur qu'il y a moins d'un an et nous
paraît donc nécessaire de prendre un peu
de temps pour que les partenaires
sociaux puissent à la fin de l'année
2023 se saisir à nouveau de ces
questions relatives à l'indemnisation
vous souhaitons donc prolonger les
règles nous souhaitons aussi les nous
souhaitons aussi travailler à les rendre
plus réactives à la conjoncture
économique puisque le système tel qu'il
existe aujourd'hui et finalement contre
intuitif avec des règles fixes ça
l'existence le système d'assurance
chômage rempli en effet un parfaitement
son rôle ainsi sur les 15 dernières
années quand le chômage était supérieur
à 10%
55% des demandeurs d'emploi était
indemnisables alors que cette part de
demandeur d'emploi indemnisables est
monté à 61% fin 2019 le SCO le chômage a
franchi à la baisse la barre des 8%.
c'est le contraire qu'il faudrait
observer si nous voulions que notre
système soit plus protecteur dans des
périodes de difficultés d'emploi par
ailleurs la France se caractérise
toujours par un taux de chômage
structurel assez élevé malgré des
tensions de recrutement et ce régime
actuel d'assurance chômage reste pensé
construit pour l'essentiel pour répondre
à un contexte de chômage de masse sans
être suffisamment incitatif au retour à
l'emploi cela explique notamment son
caractère pour qu'il le place parmi les
plus généreux d'Europe notamment pour la
question de la durée d'indemnisation ou
d'essai d'éligibilité il est donc
nécessaire de renforcer le retour un
emploi rapide lorsque les opportunités
d'emploi sont dynamiques et en revanche
quand il y aura moins d'emploi il sera
nécessaire que ses règles deviennent
plus protectrices c'est ce principe de
contrastique cité que nous sommes en
train de discuter avec les partenaires
sociaux en précisant que nous sommes
ouverts évidemment à des aménagements
sur les questions de durée d'affiliation
sur les questions de durée
d'indemnisation mais que nous ne
souhaitons pas ouvrir une concertation
ou une modulation de du montant des
indemnisations dans la mesure où le
montant des indemnisations a déjà été
modifié avec la réforme de 2019
nous voulons donc réformer ce système
pour qu'il soit plus incitatif mais nous
ne voulons pas non plus que notre
système devienne aussi strict que
d'autres pays je rappelle à ce propos
que la durée maximale d'indemnisation
est par exemple en Allemagne en Suède de
12 mois dans des pays qui ne se
caractérise pourtant pas par un manque
de protection sociale il faut aussi
souligner et c'est une chance que nous
avons que le taux de conversion c'est à
dire le ratio entre la période de calcul
des droits et la durée d'indemnisation
et de 1 pour ce qui concerne notre pays
alors qu'il est de 0,5 en Allemagne en
Italie en Irlande ou encore de 0,4 au
Pays-Bas en Espagne au Portugal nous
travaillons donc un mécanisme de
modulation des règles d'indemnisation
fonctionne en fonction de l'état du
marché du travail et la concertation
ouverte avec les partenaires sociaux
devraient durer 6 à 8 semaines pour
aboutir d'ici à la fin de l'année nous
avons à répondre à des questions
importantes sur les paramètres de
modulation mais aussi sur les
indicateurs qui nous permettent de
rendre compte du cycle économique le
plus fidèlement et le plus de la manière
la plus réactive qui soit
enfin je souhaite souligner mesdames et
messieurs les sénateurs une fois qu'ils
ont fermé le chapitre de cette
concertation autour de la question de la
modulation des règles d'indemnisation
nous ouvrirons un nouveau chapitre de
discussion avec l'ouverture d'une
négociation interprofessionnelle et donc
la recherche d'un accord national d'un
accord national interprofessionnel
majoritaire en matière de gouvernance de
l'assurance chômage ce sera l'occasion
de redonner toute sa place au
paritarisme en la matière c'est la
raison pour laquelle nous avons limité
l'application du texte de loi que nous
vous présentons à 14 mois et donc au 31
décembre 2023 je tiens enfin à préciser
deux choses pour terminer la première
pour dire que d'autres dispositions du
texte concernent la restauration de la
définition du collège électoral aux
élections professionnelles pour tenir
compte des conséquences d'une question
prioritaire de constitutionnalité qu'il
y a un article qui permet aussi la
ratification d'ordonnance que le
Parlement avait habilité le gouvernement
à prendre et des articles sur la
formation professionnelle au sujet
desquels Carole Grandjean reviendra dans
une minute
je termine en remercions l'ensemble des
sénatrices et sénateurs qui ont
participé au débat en commission des
affaires sociales au premier rang
desquels les deux rapporteurs un certain
nombre de dispositions ont été ajoutés
au texte par votre commission des
affaires sociales en matière de
contracyclicité de sécurisation
juridique de la procédure en matière
d'abandon de poste qui sont des
dispositions bienvenue et auxquelles le
gouvernement apportera évidemment son
soutien vous le savez madame leur
rapporteur et monsieur le rapporteur je
suis plus réservé quant au disposition
visant à sanctionner le refus de CDI ou
encore en matière de déplafonnement de
la durée maximale des contrats
intérimaires et plus encore pour les
restrictions apportées au système de
bonus malus que votre commission a
examiné mais nous aurons tout le loisir
dans des bases plus longuement à
l'occasion de l'examen des articles de
ce texte merci pour votre attention
la parole est maintenant à madame Carole
Grandjean ministre délégué chargé de
l'enseignement et de la formation
professionnelle
merci monsieur le président monsieur le
ministre du Travail du plan d'emploi et
de la sartion chez Olivier madame la
présidente de la commission des affaires
sociales madame de roche Madame et
Monsieur les rapporteurs chers Frédéric
cher Olivier dames et messieurs les
sénateurs
à la suite du ministre j'ai le plaisir
de vous présenter le projet que porte le
gouvernement pour la validation des
acquis de l'expérience qui s'inscrit
pleinement dans notre ambition
collective de construction d'une société
des compétences vers le plein d'emploi
pour y parvenir tous les outils à notre
disposition doivent être mobilisés et
rénover lorsque cela est nécessaire la
validation des acquis de l'expérience
fait partie de ces dispositifs connus de
nombreux de nos concitoyens et pourtant
très peu utilisé très peu utilisés au
service de leur parcours professionnel
elle a pourtant toute sa place au
service de la promotion des transitions
et des reconversions professionnelles
elle doit redevenir un outil au service
des trajectoires professionnelles de
tous les actifs plus attractives plus
simples d'accès plus modernes et plus
valorisante
elle doit s'adapter aux expériences de
plus en plus variées de nos concitoyens
tantôt fait d’engagement associatifs de
bénévolat de fonctions syndicales de
salariat d'aide familiales parce que les
compétences d'aujourd'hui s'acquèrent
dans de nombreuses situations nos
politiques publiques doivent s'adapter
c'est tout le sens de ce projet
les dispositions de l'article 4 entend
donc fonder une VAE de nouvelles
générations nous avons tous ici entendu
les critiques portées à la vaiae
d'aujourd'hui trop long trop
administratif trop complexe mal adapté à
certains profils un véritable parcours
du combattant les Français salariés
comme dirigeants d'entreprise ne citrons
pas seulement 30 000 parcours réalisés
par an l'an dernier deux fois moins
qu'il y a 10 ans la VAE est donc source
d'abandon et de trop nombreuses
désillusions
et pour cause la durée moyenne d'un
parcours est aujourd'hui de 18 mois au
cours desquels le candidat devra
franchir de nombreuses étapes et évoluer
dans un monde complexe fait de statues
et de financeurs de certificateurs et de
référentiel de compétences visées et de
preuves administratives souvent seul
face à son projet la validation des
acquis de l'expérience et pourtant
efficace à l'appui de la construction de
véritables parcours d'accès à l'emploi
pour donner du sens aux carrières de nos
concitoyens c'est pourquoi nous
promouvons une approche universaliste de
notre action dans une véritable logique
de services publics pour atteindre les
100 000 parcours d'ici à la fin du
quinquennat
les dispositions qui vous sont soumises
conduisent donc à lever les freins pour
favoriser un plus large accès à la
validation des acquis de l'expérience
nous souhaitons en premier lieu comme
vous le savez permettre un plus large
accès à la VAE des proches aidants le
gouvernement est pleinement mobilisé
pour permettre à celles et ceux qui
interrompent leur carrière pour prendre
soin d'un proche de faire reconnaître
sur le marché du travail les nouvelles
compétences acquises en situation des
danses lorsqu'elle relève de gestes
professionnels ou de compétences
transversales comme les savoir-être
la commission des affaires sociales de
votre assemblée a souhaité fixer dans la
loi le principe d'un accès universel à
la validation des acquis de l'expérience
si l'approche paraît évidemment
séduisante à première vue elle porte
toutefois le risque déjà relevé par
certaines associations d'aidant
familiaux que ce public ne soit pas
clairement
identifié par le prochain service public
ce à quoi le gouvernement veillera de
manière très attentive nous entendons
également les craintes des associations
des dents relatives à une approche
adéquationniste de la VAE des proches
aidants je veux ici rassurer les aidants
comme toutes celles et ceux qui se
lanceront dans une procédure de VAE
pourront aussi s'il le souhaite bien sûr
faire reconnaître leurs compétences en
vue d'acquérir des certifications
relevant d'autres secteurs
le texte qui vous est soumis vise
également à simplifier la procédure de
VAE ainsi que son environnement
juridique tout en sécurisant le parcours
des candidats j'ai constaté avec plaisir
que la commission des affaires sociales
et les rapporteurs ont confirmé
l'importance de ce mouvement de
simplification en acceptant tel quels
sont les dispositions que nous avons
introduites il est question dans ce
texte de simplifier le droit en posant
dans la loi les fondamentaux d'une
procédure de VAE et en renvoyant à la
compétence réglementaire les détails de
mise en oeuvre d'une nouvelle procédure
que nous voulons plus simple plus rapide
et surtout moins administratif
qu'aujourd'hui
cette simplification passe notamment par
la possibilité de faire valider par bloc
de compétences la VAE afin qu'elle
positionne au cœur les stratégies
individuelles vers l'emploi la VAE doit
également maximiser les chances de
succès de celles et ceux qui candidatent
à une certification via un tel parcours
le texte que vous allez examiner procède
ainsi au doublement du congé VAE pour
les salariés afin de leur donner plus de
temps pour préparer leur passage devant
le jury nous savons également que la
durée des parcours est une source de
réussite et il n'est plus acceptable que
les candidats soient contraints
d'attendre parfois jusqu'à 8 mois le
leur passage devant un jury c'est
pourquoi le texte propose aussi de
simplifier les règles relatives à
l'organisation et à la composition des
jurys
le texte que nous vous soumettons
aujourd'hui est enfin celui qui fera
entrer la VAE dans la modernité c'est
une VAE plus digitale plus accessible et
mieux adaptée aux enjeux du numérique
que nous vous proposons c'est ainsi dans
cette perspective que nous souhaitons
créer un véritable service public
national de la VAE qui aura la mission
de mieux piloter cette politique
publique en vue d'optimiser les parcours
et donc la réussite des candidats
c'est dans cet esprit que nous
souhaitons doter la VAE d'un espace
stratégique de coordination resserrer
autour des acteurs compétents car nous
sommes convaincus que c'est en combinant
les expertises de chaque acteur que nous
parviendrons à redorer le blason de la
VAE je tiens toutefois à dire que cet
espace de coordination n'a de chances de
réussir que s'il est agile et adaptable
ce qui implique une gouvernance du
groupement d'intérêts publics
strictement limité aux acteurs
compétents faute de quoi nous
recréerions les conditions d'une
politique publique trop complexe à
mettre en oeuvre je salue ainsi
l'engagement à nos côtés des régions qui
auront leur rôle bien sûr à jouer dans
la mise en oeuvre de cette VAE
modernisée au service des stratégies
locales de développement de l'emploi et
des compétences
pour donner une assise à ce service
public le texte propose la création d'un
espace numérique dédié point d'entrée
unique en matière d'information de
promotion et de conseils pour les
usagers le gouvernement a également
entendu la volonté des acteurs de
l'accompagnement à la VAE d'expérimenter
la possibilité d'une VAE dite inversée
son principe rendre concomitant le
processus d'acquisition des compétences
par l'emploi et la formation et celui de
la reconnaissance de ces mêmes
compétences par la VAE afin de proposer
des parcours individualisés d'accès aux
certifications dans des métiers en
tension de recrutement elle permettra
par exemple de valoriser enfin les
contrats de faisant fonction en
permettant de faire de ces périodes de
véritables tremplins vers la
certification et l'emploi durable
mesdames et messieurs les sénateurs vous
l'aurez compris nous pouvons donner un
nouveau souffle à la VAE avec cette
réforme nous allons mieux reconnaître
les compétences de chacune et de chacun
et permettre au plus grand nombre de
s'émanciper c'est un véritable progrès
social et un grand rebond culturel pour
notre pays je compte donc sur vous
toutes et tous pour voter largement cet
article et au-delà ce texte pour faire
du droit et à la reconnaissance
permanente des compétences un droit réel
et tangible je vous remercie
[Applaudissements]
Monsieur et Madame le Ministre
monsieur et madame le ministre mes chers
collègues j'ai le plaisir de saluer la
présence dans la tribune d'honneur d'une
délégation du Sénat de Côte d'Ivoire
conduite par son président Son
Excellence Monsieur Jeannot houseuku à
dio qui s'est entretenu avec le
président Larcher hier soir la
délégation est accompagné par notre
collègue André rachelt président du
groupe d'amitié France Afrique de
l'Ouest et nous pouvons saluer je crois
la grande qualité de nos relations inter
parlementaires
la Côte d'Ivoire a fait le choix du
bicamérisme dans sa constitution 2016 ce
dont nous nous félicitons
en 2020 le président l'archet avait
participé avec plusieurs de nos
collègues au premier forum du Sénat
ivoirien avec les collectivités locales
à Yamoussoukro nos deux Sénats sont
engagés depuis dans une coopération
étroite portant notamment sur évaluation
des politiques publiques et la qualité
des travaux législatifs au-delà
permettez-moi de saluer l'action du
président Ouattara pour faire de la Côte
d'Ivoire un pôle de stabilité dans un
environnement régional troublé et ses
efforts pour renouer le dialogue
politique cette voie n'est pas
nécessairement la plus facile mais elle
est la plus prometteuse
nos deux pays sont par ailleurs engagés
dans un partenariat étroit qui portent
ses fruits dans tous les domaines et
singulièrement en matière de sécurité de
défense pour mieux combattre le
terrorisme nous mesurons pleinement
l'emploi l'ampleur parlant des mesures
prises par les autorités ivoiriennes
pour protéger les Ivoiriens de ce fléau
monsieur le ministre madame la ministre
mes chers collègues en votre nom à tous
permettez-moi de salut de souhaiter à
Son Excellence Monsieur Jeannot à ossuku
à dio et à sa délégation la plus
cordiale bienvenue au Sénat français
[Applaudissements]
la parole est maintenant à Madame Frénet
depuis ça rapporteur de la commission
des affaires sociales
[Applaudissements]
merci monsieur le Président Monsieur le
Ministre madame la ministre madame la
présidente de la commission des affaires
sociales mes chers collègues l'ambition
du projet de loi d'urgence que nous
présente le gouvernement et plus limité
que son intitulé ne le sujet il s'agit
pour l'essentiel de projeter les règles
actuelles du régime d'assurance chômage
ce texte soulève néanmoins des questions
cruciales sur les objectifs la
gouvernance et le financement de ce
régime il semble en effet signé l'échec
de la réforme de la gouvernance de
l'assurance chômage
issue de la loi de 2018 puisque alors
que les règles d'indemnisation du
chômage fixé par le décret de carence du
26 juillet 2019 cesseront d'être
applicable à compter du 1er novembre
2022 aucun processus de négociation
assorti d'un document de cadrage n'a été
engagé pour définir de nouvelles règles
afin de donner une base légale et
réglementaire de fait à l'indemnisation
des demandeurs d'emploi après cette date
l'article 1er autorise le gouvernement à
prendre par décret en Conseil d'État les
mesures d'application du régime
d'assurance chômage jusqu'au 31 décembre
2023 ainsi qu'à prolonger l'application
du bonus malus sur les contributions
d'assurance chômage jusqu'au 31 août
2024 attaché à la gestion paritaire de
l'assurance chômage la Commission
considère que ces mesures dérogatoires
ne doivent être applicables que pour une
durée proportionnée à la nécessité de
l'urgence d'autant que cette urgence
résulte largement de l'abstention du
gouvernement en conséquence elle a
avancé au 31 août 2023 au lieu du 31
décembre la date limite d'application de
l'ensemble de mesures qui pourront être
prises par décret la période
d'application ne se décrit devrait être
utilisée pour engager des concertations
destinées à faire évoluer la gouvernance
de l'assurance chômage afin de tirer les
leçons de l'échec de la réforme de 2018
à cette fin la Commission a prévu
d'abroger les dispositions du Code du
travail prévoyant la procédure de
négociation des accords relatifs au
régime d'assurance chômage sur la base
de la lettre de cadrage elle a également
défini une prostituée une procédure
transitoire inspirée de l'article L1 du
Code du travail faisant intervenir le
gouvernement par le biais d'un document
d'orientation en vue de la négociation
d'un accord parallèlement à cette
restauration du paritarisme la
Commission a souhaité renforcer à
l'article premier 10 AA le cadre de
l'indemnisation du chômage elle a
d'abord proposé que le droit à
l'allocation d'assurance ne soit pas
ouvert à un demandeur d'emploi ayant
refusé trois propositions de CDI à
l'issue d'un CDD au cours des 12
derniers mois
en outre elle a jugé indispensable pour
pouvoir mettre en oeuvre et mettre en
place une indemnisation contracyclique
d'inscrire dans le code du travail que
les droits à l'allocation chômage
peuvent être modules en fonction
d'indicateurs conjoncturels 2 la
commission entendue modifier les
paramètres du bonus malus sur les
contributions d'assurance chômage en
allant bien au-delà du dispositif
proposé qui prévoit la transmission aux
employeurs des données individuelles
servant aux calculs de la modulation en
effet tel qu'il a été conçu le bonus
malus est inefficace car il ne cible pas
réellement les contrats courts les CDD
ne représentent que 2% des fins de
contrat prise en compte afin de
recentrer ce dispositif sur sa vocation
première de lutte contre la permittence
la Commission à limiter les fins de
contrats prises en compte au seul CDD
d'une durée inférieure ou égale à un
mois à l'exclusion des cas de
remplacement de salariés absents
excluant donc du dispositif les fins de
CDI et les fins conditions d'intérim en
outre afin d'atténuer les effets du
bonus malus pour les entreprises
concernées elle a limité la modulation
du taux du taux de 4,5% à plus ou moins
0,5 points au lieu d'un point la
Commission a approuvé l'article premier
10 a inséré par l'Assemblée nationale
qui prévoit que le salarié en abandon de
poste et présumée avoir démissionné
notamment au regard des règles
d'indemnisation du chômage tout en
veillant à préciser la préciser la
procédure applicable elle a également
adopté à l'article de BIS qui prévoit la
réactivation de l'expérimentation des
CDD multi-remplacements et insérer un
article de terre qui supprime la durée
maximale de 36 mois applicable aux
missions d'intérim réalisé dans le cadre
d'un CDI intérimaire enfin la commission
adoptée un amendement de notre collègue
Philippe Bas qui prévoit une procédure
plus équitable pour les collectivités
territoriales auxquelles il est demandé
d'indemniser un ancien agent au chômage
monsieur le ministre madame la ministre
vous l'aurez compris notre commission a
souhaité redonner l'initiative aux
partenaires sociaux et rendre certains
dispositifs plus juste et plus adaptés
aux besoins des employeurs et des
salariés dans un contexte de fortes
inquiétude pour l'emploi mes chers
collègues nous invitons à adopter ce
projet de loi modifier par la commission
des affaires sociales je vous remercie
[Applaudissements]
et la parole est maintenant Monsieur
Olivier nous également rapporteur de la
commission des affaires sociales
[Applaudissements]
monsieur le Président Madame la ministre
monsieur le ministre madame la
présidente de la commission des affaires
sociales pour la remercier salut et ses
qualités la manière dont elle conduit
les débats que faciliter et précision
Frédéric cuissard rapporteur pour son
allant
au sens du collectif et les dialogues
que nous avons eu tout au long de nos
discussions et puis les administrateurs
bien sûr les remercient aussi ils ont
alimenté
nos discussions et donc je pense que
nous avons tous les ingrédients pour un
bon texte voilà chers collègues en plus
des dispositions de l'assurance chômage
présenté par ma collègue rapporteur ce
texte vise également à développer la
validation des acquis de l'expérience
l'avait à eux troisième voie d'obtention
d'une certification côté de la formation
initiale et de la formation continue la
VAE permet de renforcer l'employabilité
des personnes concernées madame la
ministre l'a évoqué de favoriser la
progression des carrières et de répondre
aux besoins du marché du travail elle
permet aussi à ceux qui n'ont pas pu
accéder à la formation initiale de faire
reconnaître leur compétences trop
complexe peu connu et insuffisamment
valorisé la VAE et aujourd'hui très
sollicité on pourrait même dire que
c'est une voix qui est parfois mal aimée
comme dit la chanson de Claude François
le recours au dispositif
diminue d'ailleurs ces dernières années
le nombre de candidats diminue également
à chaque étape du parcours du dossier du
dépôt du dossier jusqu'à l'obtention de
la certification
j'ai besoin qu'on m'aime dit la va à eux
mais personne ne me comprend alors on va
essayer de la comprendre l'article 4
propose donc de renforcer
l'accompagnement des candidats et de
faciliter l'accès à la VAE les
lisibilité des proches aidants bien sûr
prise en compte des périodes de mise en
situation professionnelle
l'accompagnement des candidats dès la
constitution de leur dossier le
financement du parcours par les
associations de transition
professionnel c'est différentes
évolutions sur les bienvenus elles ont
été
substantiellement complété à l'Assemblée
nationale à l'initiative du gouvernement
et nous les partageons il est ainsi
proposé d'instituer un service public de
la VAE dont la mission est d'orienter et
d'accompagner tout demandeur d'un
groupement public réunira ainsi
notamment l'État et les régions il sera
chargé de mettre en œuvre ce service
public au niveau national il devra
favoriser l'information et l'orientation
des demandeurs promouvoir la vaae et
contribuer à l'animation et à la
cohérence des pratiques sur le
territoire la Commission a souhaité
s'inscrire dans la logique de cette
réforme en complétant le dispositif sur
deux points d'une part elle a supprimé
la longue liste des catégories de
personnes et de type d'activité
éligibles à laver à eux la nécessité d'y
ajouter les procédants a montré qu'une
telle énumération pouvait exclure
certaines personnes dont l'expérience un
petit peu correspondre à des compétences
professionnelles et méritent d'être
reconnus la commission est donc sortie
d'une approche par statue en posant le
principe selon lequel la VAE est ouverte
à toute activité en lien avec la
certification visée cette approche nous
semble plus conforme à la logique de la
réforme engagée et puis c'est notre cap
à l'image du modèle drainant le
paritarisme comme dit Frédéric mais
aussi le récit du corporatisme de tout
corporatisme d'autre part la Commission
a compléter les missions du Gyp afin que
celui-ci prenne mieux en compte les
besoins en qualification des territoires
suivant cette approche elle a prévu que
le groupement serait présidé par un
président de conseil régional de plus
les ministères certificateurs devront
déployer les moyens nécessaires au
recrutement et à la mobilisation des
jurys les acteurs de l'accompagnement
devront être soutenus y compris
financièrement et les démarches
réellement simplifier la Commission a
approuvé l'article 3 qui sécurise la
définition de l'électorat et de
l'éligibilité aux élections
professionnelles pour tirer les
conséquences d'une décision du Conseil
constitutionnel enfin l'article 5
propose la ratification sans
modification de 20 ordonnances portant
mesure d'urgence en matière de droit du
travail et d'emploi pour faire face à la
crise sanitaire ainsi que d'une
ordonnance relative recouvrement des
contributions à la formation
professionnelle cette démarche est
suffisamment rare pour être soulignée en
effet le précédent quinquennat était
marqué par un être recul dans la
ratification des ordonnances alors que
78 habilitations à légiférer par
ordonnance ont été accordés en moyenne
chaque année entre 2017 et 2022 contre
une moyenne annuelle de 36 précédemment
pour autant sur les 21 ordonnances qu'il
est proposé de ratifier 14 ne sont plus
en vigueur et une quinzième a été
annulée par le Conseil d'État au motif
que ces dispositions méconnaient le
champ de l'habilitation qui avait été
donné au gouvernement la Commission a
donc considéré qu'il n'était pas utile
de ratifier ces 15 ordonnances CQFD une
telle démarche n'ayant pour résultat que
de gonfler artificiellement les
statistiques elle a donc limité la
littératification au 6 ordonnances dont
les dispositions restent en vigueur et
donc avec ma collègue rapporteur nous
vous invitons à adopter le projet de loi
issu de nos travaux je vous remercie
[Applaudissements]
du groupe communiste républicain citoyen
écologiste ont déposé une motion 73
tendante à opposer la question préalable
au texte en discussion la parole est à
Madame A poursu poli pour la motion
monsieur le Président madame et monsieur
le ministre mes chers collègues le
groupe communiste républicain citoyen et
écologiste a décidé de déposer cette
motion pendant au rejet du projet de loi
mesure d'urgence relative en
fonctionnement du marché du travail en
vue du plein emploi alors que le
gouvernement a décidé de passer en force
à l'Assemblée nationale en dégainant le
49.3 sur la loi de finances et la loi de
financement de la sécurité sociale pour
2023 ce projet de loi habilite le
gouvernement a fixé seul les conditions
d'indemnisation des privées d'emploi
nous refusons cette remise en cause de
la gouvernance de l'assurance chômage
par les organisations syndicales et
patronales nous refusons de confier à
l'article premier les pleins pouvoirs au
gouvernement jusqu'en décembre 2023 ce
passage en force marque une nouvelle
étape du processus d'etatisation de
l'assurance chômage largement entamée
afin de servir plus directement les
intérêts du patronat
l'étape suivante pourrait être la
disparition de l'unedique et de Pôle
emploi avec la mise en place de France
travail
ce projet de loi est une remise en cause
du droit du travail au libre choix de
son travail à des conditions
satisfaisantes de travail et de
l'assurance interprofessionnelle et
solidaire contre le chômage alors que le
Sénat débute l'examen de ce projet de
loi le gouvernement a déjà lancé les
concertations avec les organisations
patronales et syndicales pour moduler
l'indemnité chômage ce mépris des
parlementaires est d'autant plus
inacceptable que lors de ces réunions de
concertation le ministère du Travail a
précisé que la modulation consisterait à
allonger la période d'ouverture des
droits au chômage
le relèvement de 6 à 8 mois sur les 24
derniers mois pour ouvrir les droits au
chômage va priver 200000 personnes
d'indemnisation et faire économiser 2
milliards d'euros sur le dos des jeunes
qui seront les principales victimes de
la modulation cette modulation ne serait
donc qu'un moyen pour faire des
économies en réduisant le nombre
d'allocataires d'ailleurs l'ensemble des
organisations syndicales de salariés ont
renouvelé leur opposition à cette
modulation même l'Union des entreprises
de proximité qui n'est pas une officine
du Parti communiste pourtant mais
l'organisation des artisans des
professions libérales et des commerçants
à critiquer je cite les doutes notamment
sur la corrélation entre la
contracyclicité et la capacité à
recruter plus facilement il nous paraît
plus important de travailler sur la
formation nous partageons totalement
cette analyse les emplois n'ont pourvu
dans notre pays ne proviennent pas de la
durée d'indemnisation chômage mais du
manque anticipation et d'investissement
dans la formation professionnelle si
nous manquons d'ouvriers qualifiés dans
l'industrie d'artisans dans le bâtiment
deux techniciens dans les services c'est
non seulement parce que les salaires
sont trop faibles et les conditions de
travail très difficiles mais encore
parce que depuis des années les
gouvernements successifs ont cassés
l'enseignement professionnel la logique
du gouvernement selon laquelle il
faudrait réduire les droits au chômage
pour inciter à la reprise du travail
relève d'une vision archaïque de
l'emploi le 14 juillet 2022 lorsque le
président de la République a annoncé
cette réforme il a présenté l'assurance
chômage comme un obstacle au bon
fonctionnement du marché du travail les
parlementaires communistes sont
particulièrement attachés à
l'émancipation des individus dans leur
travail mais cette émancipation n'est
pas possible dans la société capitaliste
qui grignote toujours davantage la
personnel au profit de la vie
professionnelle
la dégradation des conditions de travail
les faibles salaires les comportements
toxiques parfois des DRH conduisent à un
mal-être au travail et à une perte de
sens si les infirmières d'emilson de
l'hôpital c'est justement parce qu'elle
se plaignent d'une perte de sens et
qu'elle ne supporte plus de trier les
patients et de les laisser attendre des
heures
l'émancipation par le travail est
possible dès lors que les salariés
participent aux décisions de
l'entreprise avec une réduction du temps
de travail à 32 heures et avec une
augmentation massive des salaires en
entendant nous refusons d'opposer les
travailleurs avec les privés d'emploi
les travailleurs et les privés d'emploi
sont de plus en plus décisives de leurs
droits à choisir librement un emploi en
cohérence avec leurs qualification ou
leur formation ils deviennent des
variables d'ajustement du marché du
travail alors que moins de quatre
chômeurs
perçoivent une allocation et que la
moitié d'entre eux est sous le seuil de
pauvreté la réforme de l'assurance
chômage de 2019 a fait perdre 155 euros
par mois un million d'allocataires elle
a exclu 450 000 personnes de tout
allocation et a frapper les plus
fragiles et notamment nos plus jeunes
cette baisse des droits s'est
accompagnée d'un avis évincement des
privés d'emplois à la location chômage
ainsi en un an les radiations
administratives ont progressé de 40%.
avec ce projet de loi le gouvernement
reprend la main sur l'unedique qui
depuis
1958 était gérées conjointement par les
organisations syndicales et patronales
plutôt que de s'engager à reprendre les
15 milliards de dettes de lunédique
générée par le recours à l'activité
partielle durant la crise sanitaire
l'État veut transformer par décret
l'assurance
en simple filet de secours minimum cette
réforme de l'assurance chômage est un
déni de solidarité au-delà de la
diminution des indemnités des plus
précaires le gouvernement veut
transformer une assurance collective en
épargne individuelle
cette dénaturation de l'assurance
chômage est un processus à l'oeuvre
depuis plusieurs années et notamment
depuis la substitution en 2018 de la CSG
aux cotisations salariales et
l'encadrement des négociations par le
gouvernement la taxe contre les droits
les plus les plus précaires cachent des
enjeux plus structurels où le chômage ne
sera plus qu'un risque individuel il est
urgent de renouer avec la logique de
solidarité salariale
interprofessionnelle garantissant chacun
contre le risque social du chômage entre
1992 et 2001 la dégressivité des
allocations chômage n'a pas entraîné
d'accélération de la reprise de l'emploi
de la même manière les restrictions
d'accès aux droits des intermittents du
spectacle et le doublement de leur taux
de cotisations n'ont pas augmenté le
nombre de CDI dans le secteur en réalité
les chômeurs n'ont pas le choix de leur
emploi et la restriction de l'accès aux
Inde c'est chômage risque de les
contraindre à accepter des contrats
encore plus précaires contraindre à
accepter des contrats encore plus
précaires la droite et le gouvernement
semble d'accord sur de nombreux points
sur ce texte et ma collègue Laurence
Cohen il reviendra dans son intervention
mais je tiens à dénoncer la suppression
de l'indemnisation chômage pour les
salariés qui abandonnent leur poste
malgré les tentatives de nos rapporteurs
de consolider le dispositif juridique la
présomption de démission d'un abandon de
poste est un recul considérable le
phénomène d'abandon de poste n'étant ni
chiffré ni évalué il est largement
précipité de légiférer dessus d'autant
qu'avec cette rédaction vous allez
accentuer les risques juridiques nos
juridictions prudomales sont dans
l'incapacité actuellement de répondre
dans un délai d'un mois à une demande
des salariés surtout tous c'est négliger
le fait que l'abandon de poste est avant
tout une porte de sortie en cas de
conflit avec l'employeur la création
d'une présomption de démission va priver
les salariés de tout indemnisation
chômage et entraîner une explosion des
arrêts maladie face au projet régressif
du gouvernement nous portons un projet
alternatif d'une sécurité d'emploi et de
formation pour sécuriser les parcours de
vie en conclusion les sénatrices et
sénateurs du groupe communiste
républicain
citoyen et écologistes rejettent ce
projet de loi qui s'attaque aux droits
des salariés et à la gouvernance
paritaire de l'assurance chômage pour
toutes ces raisons nous avons déposé
cette motion tendance à opposer la
question préalable que nous vous
invitons à soutenir je vous remercie
[Applaudissements]
de la commission monsieur rapporteur sur
cette question préalable
monsieur le Président Monsieur le
Ministre madame la ministre
chers collègues
par principe
je ne suis jamais favorable aux
questions préalables et je pense que
c'est souvent l'opinion du Sénat parce
que ça revient à refuser de de débattre
et débattre discuter c'est en quelque
sorte ce que nous sommes et donc une
question préalable c'est une forme de
négation de ce que nous sommes et puis
il y a des arguments qui sont des
arguments juridiques parce qu'il faut
bien prolonger la convention de
l'assurance chômage sous peine de mettre
en risque les assurés et puis il y a de
nombreuses arguments politiques ils ont
été évoqués il y a question du du taux
d'emploi dans notre pays qui est une
vraie question pour créer des richesses
mais aussi pour financer notre
protection sociale il y a la question de
la VAE les aidants et les procédants qui
attendent
qui attendent pour valoriser les acquis
de l'expérience il y a les questions la
question des contrats courts qui sont
nombreux dans notre pays et qui coûte 9
milliards à la totalité des assurés des
assurés sociaux il y a la question de la
gouvernance grosse question de
l'assurance chômage la place du
paritarisme donc vous voyez toutes des
questions qui doivent être débattues ici
et qu'il n'y aurait pas de sens de de
s'en exonérer alors c'est pas parce que
le le match est difficile on peut
trouver le match est difficile délicat
mais je crois que même dans ces cas là
il faut pouvoir jouer le match et savoir
jouer le match et donc je vous invite
donc à rejeter cette question au
préalable et aborder le plus vite
possible nos débats merci à toutes et à
tous monsieur le ministre votre
appréciation
[Applaudissements]
merci monsieur le Président sans
surprise de gouvernement et défavorable
à l'adoption cette motion de rejet
j'entends je peux entendre ça tombe
d'arguments qui font d'une opposition au
texte sur des principes ça a été rappelé
par contre dans l'exposé de madame la
sénatrice il y a un certain nombre de
choses qui ont été dites et qui me
correspondent pas à ce que nous voulons
faire ni même pour une élément
particulier à la réalité vous dites
madame la sénatrice que France travail
aurait comme objectif de faire
disparaître Pôle Emploi ça n'est pas le
cas et j'ai eu l'occasion de le dire
devant la commission des affaires
sociales de cette assemblée comme de
l'Assemblée nationale nous travaillons
une meilleure coordination mais en aucun
cas la disparition de Pôle Emploi vous
présenter comme acté le fait que la
modulation amènerait à exiger 6 mois de
cotisations sur les huit mois pardon de
travail sur les 24 derniers mois plutôt
que 6 comme c'est le cas actuellement
rien de tel n'est acté et si je ne veux
pas préjugé des résultats de la
concertation avec les partenaires
sociaux je peux déjà vous dire qu'à
titre personnel si nous devons modifier
les conditions d'affiliation je
préférerais les emploie volontairement
cette formule que nous modifions la
période de référence plutôt que la
période exigée parce que souvent
l'entrée dans le marché du travail se
fait sur la base d'un CDD de 6 mois il
essayait d'être six mois sont plus
nombreux que les CDD de 7 au 8 mois vous
dites aussi que cette réforme a pour
objectif de baisser le montant des
indemnités c'est faux je l'ai dit c'est
précisé dans le document de concertation
adressé aux partenaires sociaux la
réforme de 2019 par la modification du
sgr a ramené le niveau de taux de
remplacement de la location chômage en
France dans la moyenne européenne c'est
à dire 57% et nous ne souhaitons pas le
modifier enfin vous avez présenté le
nombre de radiations administratives
comme il a augmenté de 50% en 2022
lorsqu'on regarde le nombre de
radiations administratives entre janvier
et août 2022 par rapport à la période de
janvier à août 2019 et en application
des objectifs de contrôle à la fois de
contrôle de recherche d'emploi mais
aussi de qualité administrative des
fichiers cette augmentation est de 14%
nous sommes loin des 50 que vous avez
évoqué donc pour toutes ces raisons la
vie est évidemment défavorable
en explication de vote sur la question
préalable j'ai d'abord madame Rossignol
la présidente rossignol
le plus souvent mon groupe
s'abstient sur les propositions de
question de préalable s'abstient par
amitié avec le groupe CRCE
plus rarement mais ne votent pas pour
parce que le plus souvent nous pensons
effectivement qu'il y a eu un débattre
et comme nous sommes désiréductibles
optimistes nous espérons même améliorer
les textes à l'issue de ces débats j'ai
trouvé notre collègue Katia poursuppoli
extrêmement convaincante d'autant que on
peut se poser l'action de savoir s'il y
a vraiment lieu à débattre sur ce texte
de quoi l'on nous débattre de vous
représentations du chômage
des présomptions qui pèsent sur les
chômeurs de l'idée selon laquelle si les
gens sont au chômage c'est parce qu'ils
le veulent bien et qui suffirait de
réduire les l'accès à l'indemnisation
pour qu'il retrouve la voix de l'emploi
voilà de quoi nous allons discuter nos
chances d'améliorer ce texte sont à peu
près nuls puisque le gouvernement va
trouver avec la majorité de droite du
Sénat beaucoup de points de convergence
sur toutes ces analyses que vous
partagez les uns et les autres donc on
l'espèce ce texte il faut le résumer en
fait c'est la traduction législative et
quand je dis législative je suis presque
déjà
tout à fait dans la vérité parce que
c'est la traduction d'un débat devant le
Parlement d'un texte qui est déjà en
discussion dans les partenaires sociaux
et de décision qui seront à la fin pris
par voie réglementaire donc c'est à
peine législatif donc en fait c'est la
mise en œuvre de la fameuse formule
présidentielle celle qui disait il n'y a
qu'à traverser la rue et du travail je
vous en trouve comme je ne partage pas
cette formule nous voterons la question
préalable
monsieur Chassin
monsieur le Président Monsieur ministre
madame monsieur le rapporteur même la
présidente
mes chers collègues donc si vous voulez
dans ce projet de loi je n'ai rien vu de
quelques choses qui sont péjoratifs pour
les salariés
d'abord si vous voulez
il est nécessaire que les règles
d'indemnisation du chômage qui soit
poursuivi puisqu'elle cesserait le
premier novembre il est bien sûr
nécessaire que les partenaires sociaux
participent avec le gouvernement sur les
lois d'indemnités chômage je pense que
le gouvernement a tout loisir pour le
faire et même bien sûr l'améliorer en ce
qui concerne les offres d'emploi elles
sont importantes actuellement et
lorsqu'on fait trois propositions de CDI
après un CDD bon trois propositions
quand même c'est pas être contre le
salarié le bonus le bonus malus est
amélioré et alors tout à l'heure vous
avez dit si vous voulez l'abandon de
poste il faut il faudrait absolument pas
revenir sur ce qui au niveau de la
commission c'est vrai que pour moi un
abandon de poste ne doit pas être
considéré et indemnisé comme un salarié
licencié ou une rupture conventionnelle
ce n'est pas ce n'est pas ça en fait le
salarié doit avoir des droits absolument
mais aussi des devoirs quand on a un
abandonne poste au niveau des PME c'est
très c'est très péjoratif pour
l'entreprise et enfin vraiment je salue
la VAE elle était deux fois même moins
importante qu'il y a 10 ans et elle doit
répondre au marché du travail doit être
valorisé notamment pour les emplois à
domicile et les emplois en EHPAD ou dans
les secteurs médico-sociaux et c'est
quelque chose qui va être très important
pour valoriser ces personnes qui en ont
besoin merci
également demandé à expliquer son vote
merci monsieur le Président alors
écoutez sous prétexte de prolonger
au-delà du 1er novembre délai de carence
mais qui avait vu vous fait pendant ce
délai de carence c'est un petit peu un
piège ce projet de loi est un affront au
débat parlementaire et au parités nous
sommes sommets donc de prolonger une
réforme antisociale qui depuis l'étude
d'impact à l'armante de lune et Dick n'a
pas été évaluée tout cela pour permettre
au gouvernement en fait c'est ça la
véritable raison début 2023 de légiférer
par décret lorsque les négociations avec
les partenaires sociaux auront échoué
car enfin comment croire qu'ils pourront
accepter une réforme qui prend comme
modèle le système canadien qui a
multiplié les radiations fait chuter le
nombre d'allocataires mais pas le à
l'autre chômage et approfondi précarité
et paupérisation des demandeurs d'emploi
votre gouvernement prend le problème à
l'envers en ciblant essentiellement les
demandeurs d'emploi en reportant sur eux
la responsabilité de leur situation en
fantasmant la figure d'un chômeur qu'il
convient d'activer et qui profiterait
des prestations vous faites l'économie
de réflexion structurelle sur la qualité
des offres d'emploi sur le marché du
travail sur la nécessité de changer de
travail et sur le nombre réels d'offres
non pourvu qui tourne d'année en année
autour de 6% des offres sans compter que
le texte est un texte redessiné aux
commissions en l'aggravant donc quand la
réforme vous avez un bonus malus qui est
neutre quand la réforme perd pèse
essentiellement et pour des milliards
sur les économies sur les chômeurs aussi
nous partageons le constat du groupe
communiste et nous joignons à leur
demande de rejet
monsieur mouillé
président monsieur le ministre mes chers
collègues bien entendu nous avons pas du
tout le même point de vue que l'oratrice
précédente puisque nous vivons dans nos
territoires en permanence à la rencontre
de chez entreprises de PME d'artisan qui
nous explique aux jeux des difficultés
de recrutement pour trouver du personnel
les difficultés pour conserver même le
personnel avec aujourd'hui parfois des
entreprises qui doivent modifier leur
stratégie voire même ne peuvent même
plus développer ou s'implanter dans des
territoires alors c'est pas vrai sur la
totalité de la France il faut avoir une
analyse qui soit plus précise mais on
voit bien qu'aujourd'hui c'est un c'est
une démarche généralisée en parallèle
nous voyons bien de façon alors on peut
discuter des chiffres mais le nombre
d'emplois donc pourvu est en
augmentation je crois qu'on doit à la
fois regarder très près cette réforme
qui n'est pas seul suffisante puisqu'ils
font parallèle travailler sur
l'accompagnement voilà donc nous vous
êtes nous avons plutôt un regard
bienveillant sur ce texte je tiens à
celui en tout cas également les les
articles qui conc c'est aussi une
plus-value et je pense notamment dans le
domaine du médico-social par contre je
salue le travail de la commission qui a
été vigilante notamment dans le renfort
de du pain etarisme puisque nous sommes
extrêmement vigilants sur cette démarche
là nous savons que ça fonctionne et donc
là-dessus nous avons quelques points de
différence avec le gouvernement mais la
Commission a su corriger cette points
divergence et donc au regard de tout
cela de votre compte cette notion de
censure
nous en terminons avec les explications
de vote je vais donc mettre voix enfin
consulter le Sénat sur la motion
tendance à opposer la question préalable
qui va faire l'objet d'un scrutin public
demandé par nos collègues communistes je
rappelle bien sûr que l'adoption de la
motion entraînerait le rejet du texte en
discussion
il va être procédé au scrutin public
dans les conditions fixées par l'article
56 l'avis de la commission et
défavorable celui du gouvernement
également
le scrutin est ouvert
plus personne ne demande la beauté
donc le scrutin
donc le scrutin est clos
il résultat
votant 344 exprimé 344 pour la motion 92
contre 252 la motion n'est donc pas
adoptée et nous passons à la discussion
générale
dans la discussion générale la parole
est à Madame Cohen pour le groupe CRCE
et pour 5 minutes
monsieur le président monsieur le
ministre mes chers collègues dans la
continuité de la motion présentée par ma
collègue Katia pour sooli je souhaite
dénoncer la philosophie qui justifie ce
projet de loi à savoir que les chômeuses
et les chômeurs ne voudraient pas
traverser la rue pour trouver un emploi
vous considérez les privés d'emploi
comme des fainéants et des profiteurs
alors même qu'un tiers d'entre elles et
eux ne font pas valoir leurs droits le
chômage est source de souffrance de ma
lettre et entraîne le plus souvent une
perte de confiance en soi ce que vous
refusez obstinément de prendre en compte
faut-il rappeler ici que l'assurance
chômage est un droit les difficultés de
recrutement invoquées par les
entreprises ne justifie pas une remise
en cause globale des droits de
l'ensemble des salariés ce n'est pas en
modulant les indemnités chômage que vous
allez trouver des électriciens des
couvre ou des aides à domicile pour y
parvenir il faut investir dans la
formation professionnelle et améliorer
l'attractivité des métiers notamment en
revalorisant les salaires et en
améliorant les conditions de travail
l'article premier suspend la gouvernance
paritaire du régime d'assurance chômage
au profit du gouvernement qui pourra
décider seul de moduler l'indemnisation
chômage la modulation de cette
indemnisation selon la conjoncture et
les territoires va entraîner une
fracture géographique et une disparité
temporelle entre les droits au chômage
ainsi les droits au chômage seront
différents selon le lieu et la date à
laquelle la locataire voudra y prétendre
la modulation est une remise en cause du
principe d'égalité le gouvernement peut
donc remercier la majorité de droites au
Sénat jamais avare d'un recul social
supplémentaire qui a inscrit dans le
texte le principe de contrat cyclicité
comme l'analyse le journal des échos du
20 octobre les sénateurs et l'air
ont-ils sauvé la mise à la réforme de
l'assurance chômage ils ont ajouté un
article au projet de loi pour que les
paramètres liés à l'ouverture des droits
à la location et à la durée
d'indemnisation puisse évoluer en
fonction d'indicateurs conjoncturel sur
le marché du travail fin de citation ce
recul s'ajoute au vote de l'Assemblée
nationale sous pression du Medef et du
groupe LR sur la présomption de
démission pour les abandons de poste que
les rapporteurs de notre commission ont
tenté d'encadrer sans s'attaquer aux
problèmes de fond en effet en l'absence
de données statistiques et d'études sur
les abandons de poste en France cette
disposition repose sur une
instrumentalisation de l'abandon de
poste mais surtout créerait une
procédure déséquilibrée pour les
salariés totalement inadaptés à la
réalité de la justice prud'homale non
contente des régressions de ce projet
gouvernementales a droit de sénatoriale
a ajouté un article qui supprime
l'indemnisation chômage des salariés en
CDD en cas de refus à trois reprises
d'un courant d'un contrat à durée
indéterminée autrement dit il faudrait
accepter quoi quel que soit les
conditions de travail le trajet ou les
salaires proposés cette remise en cause
des droits à l'assurance chômage n'est
pas acceptable d'autant que ce sont les
mêmes qui ont favorisé hier le
développement des CDD et refuser
l'augmentation des salaires qui
souhaitent aujourd'hui pénaliser les
salariés de la même manière la majorité
de droits de notre haute assemblée veut
favoriser le recours à l'intérim alors
que ces contrats pèsent lourdement dans
le déséquilibre du financement du
système et participe à la précarité dans
notre pays enfin la droite a tué le
dispositif de bonus malus du
gouvernement en limitant le malus de
sorte qu'il a quasiment disparu
face au projet du gouvernement et de la
droite sénatoriale nous portons un
projet alternatif qui passe par de
nouveaux moyens de financement une lutte
effective contre la précarité et les
licenciements pour les salariés il est
indispensable de rétablir les
cotisations sociales à l'assurance
chômage en supprimant en contrepartie la
CSG pour les salariés il est
indispensable de financer un service
public unifié de l'emploi et de la
formation professionnelle pour les
privés d'emploi il faut mettre en place
une véritable sécurité sociale
professionnelle qui repose sur
l'universalité de l'ensemble des
salariés afin d'acquérir des droits
individuels entièrement transférables
garantissant un montant d'indemnisation
chômage sur 24 mois bref un projet aux
antipodes de celui proposé par la goût
par le gouvernement et la majorité
sénatoriale autant de raisons pour
lesquelles les sénatrices les sénateurs
du groupe communiste citoyen écologiste
ventront contre ce projet de loi je vous
remercie
[Applaudissements]
Jean-Marie Vandenberg pour le groupe
centriste
alors monsieur le Président Monsieur le
Ministre madame la ministre mais
j'espère la revoir Madame et Monsieur
des rapporteurs chers Frédéric cher
Olivier bravo pour votre excellent
travail avec la Commission et mes chers
collègues nous connaissons tous près de
chez nous un patron qui embauche mais ne
trouve pas de personnel nous entendons
aussi tous les cancans contre le
beau-frère de la copine du voisin qui
profite du chômage voire du RSA et qui
gagne plus que celui qui travaille
c'est fait existent bien entendu mais
pensez-vous honnêtement que la vendeuse
de chez Camaïeu qui vient de perdre son
travail pourra demain être serveuse chez
Raoul le reste route question de profil
bien sûr de salaire peut-être mais aussi
de conditions de travail vous l'avez
évoqué monsieur le ministre de transport
de garde d'enfants de formation alors
monsieur le ministre
que faire
plus qu'un objectif ou l'intitulé d'un
texte ministériel je pense comme vous
que le plein emploi est une réalité
concevable et même atteignable le
travail est un droit rappelons-le
constitutionnel va institutionnel le
devoir de l'État est donc de donner à
chacun à chacune les moyens d'y accéder
mais quel chantier le texte
n'a pas la prétention de répondre à
toutes les questions en réalité il
répond à l'urgence normative du régime
d'assurance chômage plus que c'est
urgence du plein emploi certes sont
l'adoption permettra de sécuriser
l'indemnisation des demandeurs d'emploi
passer le 1er novembre et aussi d'offrir
un délai pour engager les concertations
nécessaires
mais ce délai doit surtout nous
permettre d'engager le vrai chantier de
l'assurance chômage sa gouvernance
sans réforme globale et profonde le
paritarisme aura vécu et vous y
connaissez pourtant mon attachement
comme celui de la Commission et celui de
notre groupe
je crois sincèrement dans la capacité
des partenaires sociaux a s'illustrer
ailleurs que sur les dépôts pétroliers
ou dans la rue il revient de trouver les
solutions pour équilibrer les comptes
sinon l'état prendra la main
nous pourrons le déplorer il sera
difficile de s'en étonner mais sur ce
point
le texte en réalité n'est qu'une petite
partie de la solution pour le plein
emploi pour y prétendre nous devons
changer de paradigme et c'est là qu'on
attend France travail
je vous en conjure monsieur le ministre
pas d'usine à gaz pas de super
structures miracle pas de révolution pas
de fusion de tous les acteurs de
l'emploi au fond
nos attentes sont simples ce sont celles
des demandeurs d'emploi un guichet
unique un accompagnateur unique et un
parcours personnalisé jusqu'à
l'entreprise en passant par la case
formation s'il le faut
sans ça sans cette capacité à mettre
enfin sous le même toit avec un
coordonnateur la formation l'insertion
sociale et le recrutement économique pas
de plein emploi les exemples sont
nombreux la Maison de l'emploi de
l'entreprise la formation de Vitré m'a
paraît comme la plus aboutie la maison
des chômeurs d'Arras devenue Maison de
l'Emploi et des métiers on est un autre
imparfait certes mais loin d'être isolé
je pourrais citer aussi caler
Saint-Quentin Bonneville et bien
d'autres que je connais voilà cet
engagement suppose de ne plus
fonctionner en vaselot de dépasser la
notion de chômage afin de permettre à
chacun de trouver ou de retrouver le
chemin de l'activité alors seulement le
plein emploi deviendra réalité d'ici là
l'Union centriste votera ce texte merci
à tous de votre attention
et bien la parole est maintenant madame
Maryse Carrère pour le groupe RDSE
monsieur le président monsieur le
ministre mes chers collègues Françoise
Giroud a écrit le chômage est comme une
marée noire qui recouvre l'herbe verte
là où elle a poussé atteindre le plein
emploi est un objectif que poursuivent
tous les gouvernements et malgré un
retour massif de personnes sur le marché
du travail le taux de chômage en France
se maintient à
7,4%. alors que les entreprises n'ont
jamais éprouvé autant de difficultés à
recruter la situation est inédite nous
connaissions nous connaissons bien les
effets délétères du chômage perdre son
emploi revient à perdre une partie de
son identité sociale vécu comme un échec
le chômage peut être un vrai traumatisme
pour tous ceux qui sont confrontés c'est
dans cet état dans cet esprit que vous
avez souhaité monsieur le ministre
mettre en place une stratégie globale
pour que le chômage de masse ne soit
plus une fatalité le projet de loi que
vous nous présentez aujourd'hui en est
la première étape et d'autres chantiers
suivants à cette occasion mettez-moi de
saluer le travail des maisons de
l'emploi qui constitue aujourd'hui l'un
des dispositifs d'insertion
professionnelle le plus efficace
proposant de véritables politiques de
l'emploi au niveau territorial elle
permet à de nombreuses personnes de
retrouver une activité professionnelle
et nous espérons donc qu'elles seront
financées dans le cas du projet de loi
de finances dont nous débattrons
prochainement j'en reviens au projet de
loi au sein de ce texte particulièrement
resserré une mesure cristallise toutes
les tensions l'article premier qui vise
à prolonger les règles d'indemnisation
de l'assurance chômage adoptée en 2019
mais aussi et surtout à engager une
concertation avec les partenaires
sociaux pour établir de nouvelles règles
d'indemnisation bien que vous nous vous
soyez engagés à ne pas toucher au
montant des allocations je ne vous cache
pas que les sénateurs du RDSE sont
partagés sur cette disposition nous
regrettons d'avoir allégiférer dans
l'urgence sur l'assurance chômage mais
si nous ne faisons rien des millions de
chômeurs ne pourront plus percevoir
leurs indemnités les règles réalisation
fixée par le décret de carence c'est
sans être applicable après le 1er
novembre 2022 surtout certains collègues
déplorent que l'article premier
dépouille les partenaires sociaux de
leur prérogative de gestion paritaire et
nous demande de vous signer en quelque
sorte un chèque en blanc comme le
souligne en effet le Conseil d'État dans
son avis le projet de loi ne comporte
aucune limitation directe ou indirecte
quant à l'objet ou à la portée des
dispositions du futur décret c'est
pourquoi le groupe RDSE défendra
plusieurs amendements visant à redonner
toute sa place au dialogue social nous
regrettons également que la commission
des affaires sociales est introduit un
nouvel article pour priver des salariés
d'indemnisation du chômage en cas de
refus de CDI répété cette remise en
cause des droits à l'assurance chômage
nous semble particulièrement dangereuse
elle est de nature à modifier
profondément les règles de l'assurance
chômage sans garde-fou et sans
discussion préalable et n'a pas à notre
avis sa place dans ce texte d'urgence
nous regrettons enfin qu'à l'occasion de
ce projet de loi nous ne puissions pas
traiter du dispositif territoire zéro
chômeurs sous peine que nos amendements
soient déclarés recevables au cycle au
titre de l'article 45 c'était d'autant
plus incompréhensible que l'Assemblée
nationale à quant à elle autorisé que ce
texte soit le véhicule législatif pour
réactiver l'expérimentation du CDD multi
remplacement nous avons pourtant été
alerté sur la nécessité d'alléger la
procédure pour habiliter de nouveaux
territoires et pour permettre la
poursuite du développement de cette
expérimentation le RDSE se félicite en
revanche de la réforme de la validation
des acquis de l'expérience qui permet à
toute personne d'obtenir un diplôme
grâce à son expérience souvent jugé trop
complexe par les entreprises et trop
chronophages par les candidats ce
dispositif ne s'est pas imposé dans le
paysage de la formation professionnelle
c'est pourtant un formidable outil qui
prouve que l'on acquiet qu'on en
acquiert des compétences tout au long de
sa vie et que tout n'est pas joué à
l'issue de sa formation initiale madame
et messieurs les ministres les sénateurs
du groupe RDS se seront particulièrement
attentifs au débat et réserveront leur
vote en fonction du sort qui sera
réservé à leurs amendements je vous
remercie
et la parole est à la présidente Pascal
Grigny pour les républicains
monsieur le Président Monsieur le
Ministre
Madame et Monsieur les rapporteurs
[Musique]
ce projet de Loire répond avant tout une
fois n'est pas coutume à une véritable
urgence
il s'agit de prolonger les règles
actuelles d'indemnisation du chômage qui
arrive à échéance le 1er novembre
prochain demain afin d'éviter un arrêt
soudain du versement des prestations ce
point ne prête bien sûr pas à discussion
cependant le texte va au-delà en
accordant à l'état à titre exceptionnel
la possibilité de définir de nouvelles
règles du régime d'assurance chômage au
moyen d'un décret ainsi que la relevé le
Conseil d'État le texte ne comporte
aucune limitation directe ou indirecte
quant à l'objet ou à la portée des
dispositions du futur décret
outre le blanchissant demandé au
parlementaire le projet de loi reflète
l'ascendant pris progressivement par
l'État sur la gestion de l'assurance
chômage comme les souligner récemment un
rapport présenté par notre collègue
Frédéric puissat le paritarisme recule
depuis plusieurs années dans la gestion
des dispositifs de protection sociale
que ce soit en matière de sécurité
sociale de formation ou d'assurance
chômage notamment la loi du 5 septembre
2018 pour la liberté de choisir son
avenir professionnel à modifier les
règles de négociation des conventions
d'assurance chômage en permettant au
gouvernement d'imposer les orientations
et les objectifs financiers à atteindre
par une lettre de cadrage très
strictement défini l'échec prévisible
des négociations conduites en 2019 a
abouti finalement à l'adoption d'un
décret la situation présente et
comparable mais cette fois-ci
le gouvernement Argan de l'urgence ne se
soucie pas d'engager une négociation et
précise d'ores et déjà qu'il définira
les mesures d'application du régime
d'assurance chômage par un décret en
Conseil d'État nous savons quelle mesure
introduire à ce décret il s'agit de
réaliser l'annonce de campagne du
président de la République de moduler
les conditions d'indemnisation en
fonction de la situation du marché du
travail qu'elle soit plus stricte qu'en
trop d'emplois sont non pourvus et plus
généreuses quand le chômage est élevé
une simple concertation avec les
partenaires sociaux et prévus et qui
vient d'être relancé
de modulation il n'est pourtant point
question dans le texte le gouvernement
pourra la prévoir ultérieurement ou pas
et décider seul de ces conditions
d'application
cet ensemble du disposition s’éloignant
du système paritaire que nous pratiquons
me conduit à saluer les propositions
formulées par nos rapporteurs qui sont
venus modifier l'article premier sur
plusieurs points premier point et cela
me semble plus important un amendement a
introduit le sujet de la gouvernance de
l'assurance chômage dans le texte afin
de rétablir le rôle actif des
partenaires sociaux en effet puisque la
procédure de 2018 s'est traduite par un
échec il faut revenir au fondamentaux
c'est-à-dire à l'esprit de la loi
Larcher
selon le cadre transitoire que nous
avons adopté en commission après la
publication du présent texte une
concertation sera engagée par le
gouvernement en vue d'une vraie réforme
de la gouvernance de l'équilibre
financier de l'inédit et des règles
d'indemnisation de l'assurance chômage
à l'issue de cette concertation le
gouvernement interviendra par le biais
d'un document d'orientation et non d'une
lettre de cadrage selon une procédure
inspirée de l'article L1 du Code du
travail donnant davantage de valeur à la
négociation
second point la Commission a limité dans
le temps la liberté laissée au
gouvernement pour fixer les règles
d'indemnisation des chômeurs en avançant
le délai qui lui est accordé au 31 août
2023 cette situation étant
exceptionnelle il est en effet pas
souhaitable de la laisser perdurer plus
que nécessaire
troisième point puisque cette faculté du
gouvernement vise à créer un principe de
modulation de l'indemnisation chômage en
fonction de la conjoncture nous avons
choisi d'inscrire en toute lettre ce
principe dans le projet de loi nous
considérons en effet comme légitime
l'objectif poursuivi s'attaquer aux
difficultés de recrutement que
connaissent actuellement les entreprises
en dépit d'un taux de chômage réduit à
7,4%
selon les chiffres du ministère du
Travail 60% des entreprises rencontrent
actuellement des difficultés de
recrutement ayant amené un tiers d'entre
elles à limiter leur activité chaque
jour dans nos circonscriptions des
employeurs nous disent ne pas trouver de
salariés les conditions d'indemnisation
du chômage selon diverses études jouent
un rôle important pour la reprise
d'emploi élaborer une règle d'ajustement
en fonction de la conjoncture semble
donc souhaitable et joueraient dans les
deux sens tenant compte des périodes de
croissance mais également de récession
il faut par ailleurs rappeler que même
après le durcissement opéré en 2019 les
conditions d'éligibilité à l'assurance
chômage en France reste parmi les plus
favorables de l'OCDE cependant en
l'absence d'études d'impact et de
détails sur les modalités de la réforme
notre groupe émet les plus grandes
réserves sur sa faisabilité
quels seront les indicateurs permettant
de déterminer si la conjoncture est
bonne ou mauvaise à quelles intervalles
la situation économique sera-t-elle
reconsidérée vous semblez avoir rejeté
monsieur le ministre une appréciation
par territoire mais si l'on prend en
compte la conjoncture économique
nationale pourra-t-on appliquer les
mêmes règles dans ma région des
Hauts-de-France grandementin en tension
que sur d'autres territoires alors que
le taux de chômage peut varier du simple
au double il serait préférable que
l'analyse soit faite par bassin d'emploi
voire même parfois par quartier dans
certaines villes nous comptons sur nos
débats pour obtenir des précisions de la
part du gouvernement d'autres sujets ont
été introduits dans le texte à
l'initiative de nous rapporteurs dont je
tiens à saluer la démarche pragmatique
la qualité du travail et
l'investissement sur des questions
sensibles car d'ordre social
la question avait été posée à
l'Assemblée nationale de restreindre les
droits au chômage en cas de refus
répétés de CDI suite à un CDD situation
qui nous est souvent décrite sur le
terrain notre commission a choisi
d'intégrer cette disposition et à
souhaiter que ce refus d'un emploi
stable soit particulièrement caractérisé
en fixant la suppression du droit à
indemnisation à partir de trois refus
elle a par ailleurs répondu aux
observations que vous aviez formulées à
l'Assemblée monsieur le ministre en
prévoyant une notification des refus à
Pôle emploi je tiens à préciser qu'à
titre personnel je soutiendrai
l'amendement de nos collègues Laurent
Duplomb et Bruno retaillod qui supprime
l'indemnisation du chômage dès le
premier refus de CDI car à partir du
moment où le CDI correspond même emploi
exercés auparavant en CDD il n'y a
aucune raison d'attendre un deuxième ou
un troisième CDI sauf bien sûr à ce
qu'il ait trouvé un autre CDI
dans un même esprit de justice vis-à-vis
des autres demandeurs d'emploi et par
qu'il s'agit d'une source importante de
dysfonctionnement pour les entreprises
la Commission a compléter le dispositif
introduit par les députés concernant les
abandons de poste afin de sécuriser la
procédure permettant de les assimiler à
des démissions je dirais encore quelques
mots sur les contrats courts la
commission a supprimé la durée maximale
de 36 mois applicable aux missions
accompliées en CDI ce qui permet de
sécuriser les parcours professionnels
des intérimaires tout en limitant le
recours au contrats courts elle a
également fixé pour deux ans
l'expérimentation autorisant la
conclusion de CDD pour remplacer
plusieurs salariés absents
notre sentiment sur le dispositif de
bonus malus créé en 2019 n'a pas changé
nous y voyons toujours un frein l'emploi
et une méconnaissance des impératifs de
flexibilité auxquelles sont soumis
certains employeurs le présente nous a
donné l'occasion de revoir le dispositif
afin de le recentrer sur les véritables
cas de permittence et d'alléger son
impact financier pour les entreprises
j'évoquerai enfin la VAE que nous avons
ouverte à toute activité en lien avec
une certification en dépassant l'actuel
approche par statut afin de donner un
nouvel élan à ce dispositif
insuffisamment utilisé
ainsi l'examen de ce projet de loi
malgré son ambition très limitée nous a
permis de traiter plusieurs difficultés
rencontrées par les entreprises ou les
demandeurs d'emploi et d'affirmer notre
attachement au paritarisme nous sommes
dans l'attente d'autres mesures que ce
soit sur le plan de la gouvernance de
l'assurance chômage ou sur le plan de
l'emploi car si le taux de chômage a
baissé en France il reste largement
supérieur à celui de la moyenne
européenne sous réserve du maintien des
dispositions dont nous avons enrichi le
texte notre groupe votre a ce projet de
loi je vous remercie
[Applaudissements]
garder un crédit
madame mélo à la parole pour le groupe
Les Indépendants
[Applaudissements]
monsieur le Président Monsieur le
Ministre
madame et monsieur le rapporteur
madame la Présidente de la Commission
mes chers collègues le président de la
République a mis au cœur de son projet
une ambition forte atteindre le plein
emploi d'ici 2027 cet objectif de nous
rassembler au-delà de nos sensibilités
politiques et de nos appartenances
partisanes atteindre le plein emploi
c'est permettre à chaque jeune de
trouver sa place dans la société quel
que soit son origine sociale c'est
valoriser le travail la création les
compétences et récompenser toujours les
efforts c'est enfin nous donner les
moyens de financer notre modèle de
protection sociale mais comme souvent en
politique c'est moins l'objectif qui
fait débat que les moyens mis en œuvre
pour l'atteindre
je suis sûr que nous discutions au cœur
des prochains jours seront riches je
souhaite aussi qu'elle tienne compte de
la réalité et singulièrement du travail
accompli depuis 2017 il y a 5 ans on se
demandait encore comment lutter contre
le chômage de masse qui sévissait dans
des décennies dans notre pays depuis des
décennies désormais nous en revoyons
l'espoir de vaincre pour de bons en
clair nous sommes passés d'un objectif
négatif à un objectif positif c'est loin
d'être anecdotique mais cela nous oblige
à prendre des mesures courageuses c'est
déjà ce qui a été fait au cours des cinq
années précédentes j'espère que nous
aurons de nouveau des échanges
constructifs dans cet objectif voilà la
mission qui nous est choix à nouveau
aujourd'hui avec ce projet de loi
portant mesure d'urgence relative au
fonctionnement du marché du travail en
vue du plein emploi
ce texte vise essentiellement à réformer
l'assurance chômage afin de garantir
l'efficacité et l'équité du régime lors
du précédent quinquennat les principales
réformes que ce soit sur le marché du
travail sur l'apprentissage sur la
formation professionnelle ou encore sur
l'assurance chômage ont été engagés
quand la conjoncture était plus
favorable mais ces réformes
structurelles ont permis à notre pays de
tenir bon par gros temps d'abord pendant
la crise sanitaire maintenant avec la
crise énergétique et l'inflation malgré
tout cela le taux de chômage avoisine
encore les 7% à mi-chemin entre les 10%
de l'été 2017 et les quatre pouces pour
cent visées pour 2027 c'est dire en
disant le chemin que nous avons parcours
bien sûr on pourrait dire que la
situation actuelle est nettement moins
favorable qu'elle ne l'était avant la
pandémie et pourtant grâce aux réformes
dont j'ai parlé et grâce aux mesures
d'urgence et au plan de relance le
marché du travail est très tendu ce qui
profite au travailleur malgré la
situation leur pouvoir de négociation
est bien réelle en conséquence le régime
d'assurance chômage se porte plutôt bien
les nouvelles prévisions de lunédique
publiées jeudi dernier montrent que le
régime pourrait dégager près de 13
milliards d'euros d'excédents sur la
période 2022 2024 ce sont 3 milliards
supplémentaires par rapport aux
prévisions de juin dernier cette
amélioration doit nous encourager à
faire bouger les lignes sur ce sujet
sensible il nous faut à la fois mieux
valoriser le travail et mieux protéger
pardon les demandeurs d'emploi mais je
crois que nous pourrons trouver de
nombreux consensus la commission des
affaires sociales a mené un travail
sérieux
évident la plupart des mesures du
gouvernement et en y ajoutant d'autres
mesures pour mieux valoriser le travail
je pense notamment à la notification à
Pôle emploi de tout refus de CDI au
terme d'un CDD nous avions proposé un
amant demandant ce sens en commission je
me réjouis que nous rapporteurs est
intégré une telle disposition au texte
idem pour les abandons de poste
l'Assemblée nationale a ajouté cette
disposition et nous l'accueillons
favorablement il ne s'agit pas de lutter
contre un phénomène majeur le nombre de
ces pratiques reste globalement stables
mais bien d'une question éthique on ne
peut pas octroyer une allocation à un
salarié qui abandonne son poste et la
refuser à celui qui démissionne en
respectant les procédures enfin sur la
validation des acquis de l'expérience
nous soutenons la création d'un nouveau
service public pourvu qu'elle se fasse
un moyen constante nous souhaitons que
les départements puissent y être
associés si la formation est un volet de
la politique sociale alors ils ont toute
leur place les politiques de l'emploi
doivent garantir la solidarité entre les
actifs sans compromettre la
compétitivité de notre économie cette
tension entre les objectifs apparemment
opposés nous oblige à trouver les
compromis mais il y a là rien de nouveau
sous le soleil c'est le propre du
dialogue social que de trouver des
compromis en responsabilité pour
conclure je souhaite évoquer le rôle des
partenaires sociaux dans le régime
d'assurance chômage la Commission a
souhaité accélérer le retour au
paritarisme de gestion c'est une
question de fond à laquelle nous allons
répondre le groupe les indépendants et
favorable au dialogue social mais nous
sommes aussi attachés à pouvoir réformer
le régime afin d'en préserver
l'équilibre financier je vous remercie
et la parole est à Madame pensez Monge
pour le groupe et que lui solidarité est
territoire
merci monsieur le Président Monsieur le
Ministre chers collègues nous examinons
ici le premier acte d'un vaste plan
antisocial qui de l'assurance chômage au
RSA en passant par la retraite va
émailler notre session parlementaire
sous l'égide ressuscité du travaillé
plus pour gagner plus en fait autant
dans son discours de politique générale
madame borne l'annonçait l'or serait à
travailler plus plus longtemps pour
atteindre la pleine emploi à 5% et se
conformer aux orientations de rigueur
budgétaire du programme de stabilité aux
recommandations du semestre européen et
régulièrement du Conseil d'analyse
économique comme toujours la doxa
néolibérale guide le gouvernement qui
justifie sa politique de stigmatisation
des chômeurs par la nous avons d'un faux
paradoxe entre les emplois non pourvu et
le nombre de chômeurs déjà en 2003
François Fillon jugeait inacceptable et
300 000 emplois non pourvu chiffre 116
agité depuis 20 ans jusqu'à récemment
sans analyse sérieusement de son contenu
et de sa pertinence pour justifier ce
prétendu paradoxe en regard du chômage
la réalité c'est que selon les chiffres
de Pôle emploi sur les 3,2 millions
d'offres d'emplois recueillis et
clôturés en 2018 seul 157 millions ont
été non pourvus et il y a plus en 2021
soit de 5 à 6% du total des offres la
réalité c'est que même si ces offres
trouvaient preneur elles sont largement
insuffisantes pour combler le chômage
endémique et offrir des opportunités ne
serait-ce que 3 millions de chômeurs de
la catégorie A la réalité c'est que la
majeure partie de ces oeuvres d'emploi
non pourvu ont reçu plusieurs réponses
de candidature mais quels ont été
rejetées par les employeurs et que selon
Pôle emploi je cite les trois quarts des
recruteurs d'une offre non plus
reconnaissent que les conditions de
travail du poste proposé peuvent
décourager le candidat les offres non
pourvu résiduelles ont donc avoir
essentiellement avec la qualité de
l'offre d'emploi et des conditions de
travail et non du fait de chômeurs non
actifs dans leur recherche d'emploi la
DARES souligne dans une enquête sur les
métiers en tension en 2021 en expliquant
que les difficultés d'embauche étaient
liées aux conditions de travail au
salaire insuffisants au point que selon
l'OFCE 60% des chômeurs non indonés ne
les accepte pas non plus de sorte que
vous pouvez bien faire une énième
réforme de l'assurance chômage cela ne
changera rien à cette tension et vous le
savez le premier objectif c'est bien la
recherche d'économies en abaissant les
droits des demandeurs d'emploi dans un
pays toujours plus inégalitaire dans le
partage de la richesse ces réformes
successives de l'assurance chômage
ciblant énormément d'heures d'emploi
sans s'attaquer aux problèmes
structurels de la qualité des offres
d'emploi entraîne le pays sur le chemin
d'un plein emploi répressif où sont
attaqués les capacités d'arbitrage des
chômeurs les études sur le modèle
canadien promus dernièrement le montre
l'augmentation de la durée d'affiliation
la baisse de la durée d'indemnisation ou
du taux de remplacement comme la
territorialisation on pourrait fait de
contraintes d'une partie des chômeurs
soit accepté des emplois mal rémunérés
de moindre et de moindre qualité soit à
se voir radié cela entraîne des
externalités négatives car la baisse des
indemnités chômage pèsent sur le niveau
général des salaires vous vous attaquez
au pouvoir d'arbitrage des chômeurs
après avoir faibli la capacité de
négociation des salariés eux en poste
via les ordonnances Macron et les lois
de travail antérieures c'est la même
politique et pour ce qui est des
écologistes nous ne ferons pas l'erreur
de les opposer comme le discours nous y
invite vous défendez une société du
travailler plus et prête et prétendument
de la valeur de travail alors que
l'avenir appartient au partage et à la
baisse du temps de travail d'abord pour
une raison ancienne pointée déjà par
Marc je cite mais oui écoutez la
condition essentielle de
l'épanouissement et la réduction de la
journée du travail vous refusez de voir
que la vague de démission traduit une
demande de transformation du travail de
passage des bullshites shop de David
kreber a des emplois émancipateurs à
l'utilité sociale et environnementale
ensuite parce que votre modèle
productiviste explose une à une les
limites de la biosphère et qu'il nous
faut
urgemment ralentir nous défendons la
sécurisation du parcours professionnel
loin de la précarisation et de la
paupérisation de ces réformes
successives
le temps est venu non de se travailler
plus mais de reprendre la marche vers la
réduction du temps de travail que permet
le partage des richesses et que et
qu'ils doivent respecter les limites
planétaires c'est pourquoi le groupe
écologique votera contre ce projet de
loi je vous remercie
[Applaudissements]
la parole est à Monsieur lévrier pour le
groupe herbes des pays et pour 6 minutes
monsieur le Président Monsieur le
Ministre madame la présidente de la
commission des affaires sociales madame
et monsieur le rapporteur mes chers
collègues le plein emploi en France
n'est pas une utopie un simple chiffre
factuel le taux de chômage au sens du
BIT a baissé de 2,2 points depuis
l'arrivée d'Emmanuel Macron à l'arrivée
à l'Élysée absolument force est de
constater que la réforme de 2019 engagée
en 2019 porte pleinement ses fruits la
part des contrats courts dans les offres
d'emploi disponibles diminue plus de la
moitié des embauches sont signés en CDI
contre 30% 2019 et au sein des 7
secteurs les plus exposés au contrats
courts 62% des entreprises auront un
bonus en 2022 ces chiffres montrent dans
le contexte économique que nous
connaissons une volonté des entreprises
de préférer des contrats longs et des
renouvellements au contrats courts et
précaires
pour autant si l'amélioration est
particulièrement marquée la France
compte encore 7,3% d'actifs sans emploi
c'est encore trop et c'est la raison
pour laquelle le président de la
République et la première ministre ont
mis l'objectif du plein emploi pour 2027
au cœur de votre feuille de route le
projet de loi que vous soumettez avec
Madame la Ministre Carole Grandjean à la
représentation nationale est une
première étape vers cet objectif pour
l'atteindre vous prolongez les règles
d'indemnisation de l'assurance chômage
issue de la réforme de 2019 en raison de
la pandémie ces règles sont entrées en
vigueur il y a à peine un an c'est trop
peu pour en observer les premiers effets
une série de travaux d'études et de
recherche pour les évaluer et d'ailleurs
en cours
vous ouvrez une concentration
approfondie avec les partenaires sociaux
pour rendre les règles plus réactives à
la conjoncture économique et à
l'évolution du marché du travail c'est
un engagement du Président il est
nécessaire d'avoir des règles
incitatives à la reprise de l'emploi
quand les conditions économiques sont
favorables et inversement de pouvoir
compter sur un système plus protecteur
quand l'économie va mal quand des
emplois sont détruits
vous lancez une négociation pour
redéfinir la méthode de gouvernance de
l'assurance chômage les partenaires
sociaux et l'État partagent le souhait
de faire évoluer la gouvernance pour
mémoire les partenaires sociaux n'ayant
pas réussi à trouver un accord
majoritaire l'État a dû reprendre la
main il a dû édicter des règles de
l'indemnisation de l'assurance chômage
par décret de carence celui-ci ne peut
avoir une durée de vie supérieure à 3
ans ce décret du 26 juillet 2019 relatif
au régime d'assurance chômage des
travailleurs privés d'emplois fixes
jusqu'au 1er novembre 2022 les règles
fixent pardon jusqu'au premier novembre
2022 les règles d'assurance chômage en
conséquence ce texte s'impose à nous
d'un point de vue calendaire
vous proposez une clarification des
dispositions du Code du travail afin de
rétablir la base légale relative aux
conditions pour être électeur aux
élections professionnelles vous posez et
c'est d'importance les premiers jalons
d'une réforme de la VAE qui va la rendre
plus attractive et plus et plus
accessible afin de parvenir à initier
100 000 parcours de VAE chaque année
d'ici la fin du quinquennat vous
simplifiez et moderniser les conditions
d'accès afin d'en faire un instrument
simple au service de tous les actifs qui
souhaitent évoluer dans leur carrière la
VAE qui célèbre cette année ses 20 ans
constitue un dispositif pertinent et
efficace de promotion d'évolution et de
transition professionnelle il est
pourtant sous utilisé et mal connu donc
de nos concitoyens avec seulement 30 000
parcours réalisés en 2021 contre 60 000
il y a 10 ans
fondé sur le principe de la
reconnaissance des compétences acquises
tout au long de la vie cet outil permet
d'accéder à une certification reconnue
et développe ainsi l'employabilité de
tous les actifs en particulier les moins
qualifiés et les plus éloignés de
l'emploi
poursuivant cet objectif ce texte ouvre
l'accès à la VAE pour des proches des
dents la reconnaissance des compétences
acquises au contact d'un proche en
situation de handicap de perte
d'autonomie ou accompagner à la fin de
sa vie leur permettra d'initier un
parcours vers des certifications pour
des métiers en forte tension de
recrutement à l'instar des auxiliaires
de vie des aides-soignants la majorité
sénatoriale propose un amendement qui
ouvre des pistes on est en élargissant
le public cible mais la réforme
vient-être amorcée et c'est sans doute
prématuré pour conclure tous ces leviers
précédemment cités doivent d'une part
permettre de répondre à la pénurie de
main d'oeuvre en augmentant le nombre de
personnes aptes à occuper un métier en
tension et accompagner valoriser les
reconversions professionnelles des
salariés si notre groupe mesure la
nécessité du projet de loi portant
première mesure d'urgence relative au
fonctionnement du marché du travail en
vue du plein emploi et des modalités
qu'il introduit il s'interroge quant à
l'intérêt de certains amendements
rapporteurs notamment concernant le
développement de l'intérim ou encore les
modifications des paramètres du bonus
malus nous proposerons avec plusieurs
collègues un amendement visant à revenir
sur la suspension des allocations
chômage suite à trois refus de CDI je
vous remercie
si la parole est maintenant madame
Monique Lubin pour le groupe socialiste
écologiste et républicain
[Applaudissements]
monsieur le Président Monsieur le
Ministre madame et monsieur le
rapporteur mes chers collègues nous nous
émouvons souvent sur les bancs de
l'opposition de l'insuffisance des
études d'impact accompagnant les projets
de loi du gouvernement et nous nous
inquiétons de sa propension à accumuler
les réformes radicales en faisant fi du
travail par le menteur sans jamais se
donner le temps de l'évaluation le
présent projet de loi ne fait pas
exception ils se fonde sur une poignée
d'idées hâtives qu'il a malheureusement
en partage avec la majorité du Sénat au
titre de ces idées hâtives les
demandeurs d'emploi seraient largement
indemnisés il faudrait inciter plus
violemment les actifs en situation
d'emploi discontinuent à reprendre un
travail pérenne l'assurance chômage leur
serait trop favorable notre système
d'indemnisation les inciterait à
s'enfoncer dans la paresse et la fraude
une étude de Mathieu Grégoire est claire
vivesse basse ses idées en brèche
publiées dans la revue de l'Institut de
recherche économique et logiciel il
reste elle porte sur l'évolution des
droits à l'assurance chômage de 1979 à
2021 elle établit en matière
d'indemnisation au chômage l'affirmation
selon laquelle les droits des salariés à
l'emploi discontinue à progresser
jusqu'à dépasser les droits des salariés
stables apparaît en complet décalage
avec les résultats des simulations mises
en place c'est le contraire qui se
dessine l'indemnisation totale d'un
salarié payé au smic à mi-temps subit
une perte spectaculaire depuis 1979 en
2019 le montant perçu par ce salarié est
inférieur de 50% par rapport à ce à quoi
il pouvait prétendre en 1979
la réforme de l'assurance chômage du
premier quinquennat possédait des
préjugés ici battus en brèche elle a
toujours selon la même étude radicaliser
l'évolution de l'assurance chômage vers
une logique de compte épargne on y est
indemnisé en fonction non pas du salaire
mensuel mais du salaire journalier cela
conduit je cite à inverser la hiérarchie
des niveaux d'indemnisation entre eux
alors que les plus exposés au chômage
étaient les mieux indemnisés ils sont
désormais les moins bien indemnisés le
gouvernement avec le présent projet de
loi promet de continuer sur cette lancée
Matthieu Grégoire et Claire vivait
signal par ailleurs que les publications
officielles tendent de ta communiquer
sur le taux de couverture de
l'indemnisation du chômage pour définir
ce taux ces publications renvoient n'ont
pas au chômeur indemnisé mais au chômeur
indemnisables ça fait une sacrée
différence à partir de 2014 et jusqu'en
2019 le différentiel entre les
indemnisables et ceux qui sont
effectivement indemnisés
soit en effet de 5,4 points c'est plus
du quart des personnes dites couvertes
par les systèmes d'indemnisation chômage
qui ne perçoivent aucune indemnisation
en 2018 comme le souligne l'IRES on peut
considérer qu'à l'heure que le nombre de
demandeurs d'emploi n'a jamais été aussi
élevé avec près de 5,725 millions de
personnes inscrites en catégorie ABC en
janvier le taux de couverture a atteint
son niveau le plus bas de l'histoire et
de l'indemnisation du chômage en juin
49,5%. communiquer sur le taux de
couverture en évoquant dans le
sous-texte que les indemnisables c'est
faire miroiter un système d'assurance
chômage plus généreux qu'il ne l'est et
ce n'est pas innocent
c'est un sincérité donc fait preuve
l’exécutif et l'une des raisons pour
lesquelles nous nous opposons à
l'article premier du présent de texte au
nom d'une nécessité administrative
exploitée à des femmes politiques il
prétend conférer au gouvernement toute
latitude pendant de longs mois pour
modifier les règles de l'assurance
chômage sont plus se soucier du
Parlement ou des partenaires sociaux
pour mémoire comme le rappelait en 2001
Bruno pallier au moment de faire les
choix d'orientation de la sécurité
sociale en 1945 une coalition d'intérêt
se dresse contre l'intervention de
l'État pour le dialogue social et une
mise au responsabilité des partenaires
sociaux c'était une demande des
syndicats elle a rencontré la volonté de
Pierre Laroque de mettre en place des
corps intermédiaires dans lesquels les
représentants des salariés et des
patrons auraient un rôle à jouer ce
choix de promouvoir les partenaires
sociaux s'est accompagné de celui de
reconduire la logique assurantielle pour
les allocations chômage le but était
selon Bruno pallier d'intégrer les
travailleurs en leur proposant de
particip à la gestion du système de
protection sociale selon le principe si
vous payez vous gérez pierre Laroque ne
voulait pas que le système de protection
sociale soit financé par l'impôt car
alors les dépenses sociales seraient
soumises à la contrainte budgétaire
c'était signifié que la demande sociale
vient en premier et le financement
seulement ensuite dans un système qui
privilégie d'abord les droits et
envisage dans un deuxième temps
l'ajustement financier c'est dans cette
logique que les tricotent votre
politique et le présent projet de loi
avec la désocialisation à marche forcée
de notre système de protection sociale
vous ne réservez aux partenaires sociaux
qu'un strapontin voir un siège éjectable
le choix fait ici comme ailleurs de ne
pas parler de négociation mais de
concertation illustre demeurant la place
que vous leur réservez
l'introduction par la droite au cours de
l'examen de ce texte à l'Assemblée
nationale et au Sénat de mesure de plus
en plus restrictives concernant l'accès
à l'assurance chômage témoigne par
ailleurs d'un accord profond du
gouvernement avec la supposée opposition
de droite la transformation de l'abandon
de poste en démission un test du choix
de gouverner au préjugés et d'une
volonté d'incriminer le travailleur rien
je dire bien rien nos documents d'une
pratique qui soit abusive massive
illégitime de l'abandon de poste au
contraire ce qui recourt doivent pouvoir
le faire pour se soustraire à toute
configuration telle que demeurant à son
poste le travailleur mettrait en danger
sa santé physique ou psychique ou se
verrait victime d'abus
je ne sais pas par ailleurs je ne sais
par ailleurs même pas si il est
nécessaire de commander de commenter
l'amendement introduit dans le texte par
la majorité en commission des affaires
sociales du Sénat cet amendement créé en
effet une possibilité supplémentaire de
priver un demandeur d'emploi de ces
indemnités et il le fait sur une base
nébuleuse je serai très curieuse de
savoir où il prend ses fondements il
part en effet d'une situation qui relève
d'une exception celle d'un demandeur
d'emploi qui aurait refusé sur une
période de 12 mois trois offres de CDI à
la suite d'un CDD cette offre de CDI
portant sur un emploi similaire et étant
rémunéré au même salaire quelles sont
les études qui établiraient que cette
situation soit une donnée statistique
critique justifiant la mise en place de
cette mesure on ne peut pas construire
une loi à partir de considération non
documentée
dans le même mouvement vous avez inscrit
la contrat cyclicité comme principe de
modulation des indemnités chômage dans
le code du travail la conjonction de ces
deux innovations dispensables à pour
résultat que nous concitoyens dans la
perspective de recharger leurs droits à
indemnisation et pour survivre pourront
être amenés à accepter un CDD sous
qualifier ou sous-payés et se voir
obliger de rester dans cet emploi CDI
sous peine d'être radié vous semble et
tenter d'instituer un droit de
réquisition des travailleurs banalisés
dans notre code du travail
mise en avant par le gouvernement pour
promouvoir son projet de loi la
promotion de la validation des acquis de
l'expérience comme voie d'accès aux
proches aidant et aux aidants familiaux
à une professionnalisation suscite quant
à elle des réserves comme l'expliquera
ma collègue Michel meunier au moment où
l'on parle de sens du travail de grande
démission de souplesse et de qualité de
vie de juste rémunération le
gouvernement et ses alliés répondent
rétorsion suspicion et incrimination des
travailleurs loin de ces dérives j'ai
déjà eu l'occasion de rappeler qu'il ne
peut y avoir de valeur travail sans
valeur son travail de valeur rien ne
peut se faire en réduisant les
travailleurs aux statut d'unité de
production dépouillés de droit Robert
Castel rappelle que le salarié n'a pas
gagné sa prime a gagné sa prééminence
que parce qu'à partir de la condition
salariale par la mise en place de droits
et étant attachés un état social a été
mis en place avant cela on était salarié
lorsqu'on était rien et que l'on n'avait
rien à échanger hormis une force de ses
bras notre système social notre
assurance chômage ont été mises en place
pour nous permettre de faire société et
intégrer les travailleurs le
gouvernement et ses alliés choisissent
de les maltraiter de faire taire leur
représentants à coups de 49-3 et de loi
dont la sincérité interroge renforcer la
cohésion sociale et plus que jamais
nécessaire nous sommes à un moment de
notre histoire nous avons besoin de
refaire société et ce besoin le
gouvernement le prend complètement à
rebours face à son inadéquation
fondamentale avec les besoins du pays
nous voterons contre ce projet de loi
qui tourne le dos au fondement de notre
démocratie sociale
[Applaudissements]
et Madame Alec Annick Jacquemet conclut
la discussion générale pour l'Union
centriste
[Applaudissements]
monsieur le Président Monsieur le
Ministre Madame et Monsieur les
rapporteurs madame la Présidente de la
Commission mes chers collègues
comme nous le savons le droit du travail
est un domaine plus que complexe en
effet il organise les droits et de voir
de l'ensemble des employeurs et des
travailleurs afin de garantir
l'équilibre entre les parties et de
protéger chacune d'entre elles l'enjeu
qu'il neutre et de faire évoluer notre
droit pour rester au plus près du fait
social sans entacher les acquis-passer à
ce titre nous devons également garantir
l'application des protections sociales
associées nous rapporteurs dont je salue
l'excellent travail l'ont assurément
mené en suivant ces objectifs de bon
sens
c'est pourquoi ce projet de loi
s'attache dès son article premier à
donner une base légale et réglementaire
à l'indemnisation des demandeurs
d'emploi à compter du 1er novembre 2022
il autorise le gouvernement à prendre
par décret les mesures d'application du
régime d'assurance chômage jusqu'au 31
décembre 2023 cette mesure dérogatoire
est proportionnée à la nécessité de
l'urgence permettra au paritarisme de
signer un accord portant sur l'assurance
chômage dans un délai rapide mais
suffisamment important pour le bon
déroulement des échanges par ailleurs il
prolonge jusqu'au 31 août 2024
l'application du bonus malus
à l'article 2 la Commission a précisé
utilement le champ d'application et
c'était nécessaire le bonus malus permet
de dissuader de dissuader la
généralisation des contrats précaires et
à l'inverse de récompenser les
entreprises plus vertueuses sur ce sujet
l'article aménage le dispositif en
permettant la transmission aux
employeurs de la liste des anciens
salariés pris en compte pour le calcul
du bonus malus attendu par le secteur
cette mesure semble de nature à
améliorer la transparence du dispositif
l'article 4 porte sur la validation des
acquis de l'expérience cet article
concernait d'abord le secteur
médico-social et en particulier celui de
l'aidance notre groupe se réjouissait
déjà de cette bonne évolution en faveur
des aidants cet article largement
complété réforme désormais plus
profondément la validation des acquis de
l'expérience tout en sécurisant le
dispositif
la création d'un jeep devrait contribuer
à l'information des personnes et à leur
orientation dans l'organisation de leur
parcours à la promotion de la VAE ainsi
qu'à l'animation et à la cohérence des
pratiques sur le territoire
par ailleurs la navette parlementaire a
enrichi ce texte de plusieurs
dispositions notables
la présomption de démission en cas
d'abandon de poste s'il conviendra
remarquer que certains abandons de poste
sont totalement justifiés il est aussi
vrai qu'un fort dévoiement du principe
est observé dans les fêtes or il n'est
plus souhaitable qu'un salarié licencié
à l'issue d'un abandon de poste dispose
d'une situation plus favorable en
matière d'assurance chômage qu'un
salarié qui démissionne en faisant
présumer la démission de l'intéressé
l'article tente en sécuriser le bon
usage du droit en fin de relation
contractuelle toutefois sans la soupape
de sécurité du dispositif ce nouveau
principe aurait pu être largement
criticable regarde au regard des
abandons de postes justifiés par des
situations parfois dramatiques
l'expérimentation du CDD multi
remplacement a été réactivé cela était
nécessaire dans la mesure où
l'expérimentation a été peu contributive
en raison de la crise sanitaire les
conclusions de celle-ci permettront je
l'espère aux employeurs de recruter avec
un seul contrat une personne pour
remplacer plusieurs salariés d'une même
entreprise pour conclure et malgré que
le titre de ce projet de loi semble plus
ambitieux que les mesures qu'il compose
le groupe Union centriste votera en
faveur de ce texte je vous remercie
merci madame la Présidente merci madame
monsieur mélisse vous souhaitez conclure
la discussion générale vous avez la
parole
merci beaucoup monsieur le Président
quelques mots d'abord pour remercier
l'ensemble des intervenants de cette
discussion générale et tout
particulièrement celles et ceux qui ont
souligné que ce texte apporte un certain
nombre de mesures en matière de réforme
des règles de l'assurance chômage en
matière de validation des acquis de
l'expérience mais qu'évidemment ce texte
ne peut pas être le seul en matière
d'emploi ça ne peut pas être le seul
outil les questions relatives à la
formation à l'accompagnement des hommes
et des femmes les plus éloignés de
l'emploi les questions relatives à la
formation initiale je pense à la réforme
de la voix professionnelle ou encore au
développement de l'apprentissage sont
autant de sujets qui nous permettront
d'aller vers le plan d'emploi et
j'aurais pu ajouter en écho à des
concertations menées actuellement les
aspects relatifs au travail des seniors
au taux d'emploi des seniors pour
reprendre le terme consacré ou encore
aux conditions de travail et donc nous
irons évidemment plus loin nous aurons
d'autres occasions de discuter d'outils
permettant d'aller vers le Pôle Emploi
au-delà des seuls dispositions de ce
texte il ressort sur le président des
discussions en tout cas des
interventions quatre thèmes qui je crois
vont peut-être structurer nos débats nos
le premier concerne la place du
paritarisme et nous y reviendrons dans
un instant avec un amendement du
Gouvernement que je proposerai à votre
assemblée pour établir la rédaction de
l'article la Commission les affaires
sociales sur proposition de madame le
rapporteur je crois
modifier cet article 1 en limitant la
durée et la date butoir d'application du
texte et en prévoyant une forme
dérogatoire pour organiser le dialogue
social autour de la gouvernance de
l'assurance chômage je suis assez
convaincu qu'au-delà des choix fait par
la commission des affaires sociales et
de ceux du gouvernement une forme de
consensus peut naître autour de ce sujet
là nous l'avons effectivement pas ouvert
de négociations interprofessionnelle
autour des questions d'indemnisation au
moment où nous aurions dû le faire c'est
à dire au moment de l'élection
présidentielle pour respecter les délais
propre à la recherche d'un ami ce qui
nous amène dans la situation d'urgence
que nous connaissons et ce qui nous
amène donc à demander une prolongation
possible des règles jusqu'au 31 décembre
2023 de manière à ce que cette date soit
cohérente avec d'autres éléments de
calendrier j'y reviendrai par contre sur
les questions de gouvernance le rôle du
paritarisme je me suis engagé et c'est
l'occasion pour moi de le répéter devant
vous auprès de tous les partenaires
sociaux l'ouverture du négociation et
d'une négociation qui soit négociation
très ouverte il y a quatre grandes
familles de scénarios pour la
gouvernance de l'assurance chômage un
seul ne recueille pas la sentiment du
gouvernement c'est celui de
l'étatisation de l'assurance chômage
mais pour les autres le document sur
lequel nous engagerons cette négociation
sur un document ouvert permettant
justement à la négociation d'aller au
bout de tous les aspects deuxième sujet
qui peut faire débat concerne l'abandon
de poste je voudrais d'abord dire à
Madame madame la sénatrice Cohen qui a
madame avait raison sur le fait qu'il
n'y a pas d'agrégat statistiques précis
permettant de mesurer le nombre
d'abandon de poste les abandons de poste
donnent lieu à des licenciements pour
faute grave et donc ce que nous pouvons
mesurer c'est l'évolution du nombre de
licenciements pour faute grave quand on
regarde le nombre de CDI faisant l'objet
d'une rupture pour licenciement pour
faute grave
une augmentation est assez conséquente
mais elle est proportionnelle à
l'augmentation du nombre d'emplois en
CDI dans le pays et donc on peut
considérer qu'il n'y a pas d'évolution
majeure par contre lorsqu'on regarde le
nombre de licenciements pour faute grave
concernant des employés en CDD il y a un
doublement du nombre de licenciements et
je fais procéder ainsi de recherche mais
il apparaît très vraisemblable que ce
soit cette vague d'abandon de poste que
nous connaissons notamment sur les CDD
en particulier dans des secteurs comme
l'hôtellerie les cafés les restaurants
qui expliquent cette augmentation par
contre là où nous aurons un débat c'est
que nous considérons effectivement que
l'abandon de poste là ce qui n'est pas
justifié par une mise en danger et c'est
en cela que j'accueille très
favorablement les évolutions apportées
par la commission des affaires sociales
l'abandon de poste il n'est pas
justifiée par cette mise en danger est
une rupture unilatérale d'un engagement
contractuel qui doit s'apparenter à une
démission ça n'est pas un droit que
d'obtenir une indemnité inédite après
avoir procédé un abandon de poste si
celui-ci n'est pas motivé par un danger
ou des questions liées à la sécurité y
compris parfois des formes de
maltraitance troisième sujet qui va je
crois occuper beaucoup de nos débats la
question du bonus malus il revient pas
simplement pour dire que certaines
arguments dont j'ai été évoqués pour
justifier du maintien de cette procédure
nous vous proposons de le faire avec un
horizon 31 décembre 2024 pour respecter
les cycles d'observation et de mise en
œuvre de trois ans tels que prévu
pendant la loi de 2019 mais je m'arrête
là pour me poser trop long nous y
reviendrons et enfin la question des
refus de CDI à l'issue d'un ou de
plusieurs CDD j'ai dit mes plus grandes
réserves sur l'amendement adopté en
commission elles sont par définition
encore plus importante pour l'amendement
qui vise à appliquer une forme de
sanction dès le premier refus d'un CDI
il y a plusieurs raisons à cela des
raisons très pratiques mais aussi les
raisons de fond je considère que lorsque
un salarié embauché pour une durée
déterminée étalée au bout de son
engagement contractuel sans à aucun
moment revenir sur l'engagement qu'il a
pris il n'y a pas de raison de le
sanctionner
il refuse de continuer ou de prolonger
dès lors que lui-même a tenu
l'intégralité des engagements pris
initialement j'ajoute par ailleurs que
le code du travail prévoit d'ores et
déjà en cas de proposition d'un CDI dans
les mêmes termes que le CDD et il faut
souligner cette égalité des termes la
possibilité pour l'employeur de ne pas
verser la prime de précarité si
l'employeur démontre qu'il a proposé un
CDI dans les mêmes conditions que le CDD
qui s'achève enfin beaucoup de
d'intervenants ont évoqués la validation
des acquis de l'expérience je n'y
reviens pas les débats sur l'article 4
permettront à un ministre délégué Carole
Grandjean dont je précise qu'elle nous a
quittés pour assister et me représenter
aussi aux questions d'actualité au
Gouvernement de l'Assemblée nationale
aura l'occasion de s'exprimer devant
vous et de répondre à l'ensemble de vos
questions
merci Monsieur le Ministre donc nous
[Applaudissements]
pouvons conclure pardon la discussion
générale et nous passons à la discussion
du texte de la commission et à l'article
premier monsieur mouillé la parole
merci monsieur le président monsieur le
ministre mes chers collègues à
l'occasion de l'examen de ce premier
article je tiens à prendre